Tucker Carlson appeared on the uh on
Adam Kroll's podcast and he warned that
Democrats will do anything to stop Trump
but they're not going to do lockdowns
they're not going to do covet in fact he
says they're going to start war with
Russia in an effort to defeat Trump and
that makes sense when presidents are
facing War they tend to receive
substantial support but I'm not entirely
convinced we'll see the way Joe Biden
screwed up Afghanistan I'm not sure
people really trust his foreign policy
and if they do start a war Donald Trump
will promise to end it diplomatically
and that may actually work with the
American public
Tucker Carlson also said that Barack
Obama is gay likes having uh adult
relations with males and smokes crack in
that same interview I guess we'll talk
about that and uh as a bunch of other
stories too we got secretaries of state
are ramping up the effort to remove
Trump from the ballot so things should
get pretty wild of course now we've got
a uh the left is claiming
the Maui fires were caused by
white people I know I know it's hard to
say but it's time everyone admits it
colonialism oh wow that's what they're
saying they're saying white Colinas
destroyed Hawaii whatever we'll talk
about that too my friends before we get
started head over to timcast.com click
join us become a member to support the
show over at Tim guest.com you'll get
access to the members only uncensored
show Monday through Thursday at 10 p.m
where you as a member can call into the
show and talk to us and our guest ask us
questions and uh it's really it's a lot
of fun these members only shows are a
bit not family friendly and ladies and
gentlemen I do believe the timcast app
is now available in the Google Play
Store so open up the Google Play Store
on your Android phones type in timcast
and please be there because it'd be
really funny if it's uh there it is
wonderful if you go on Google Play you
can actually install the timcast app and
listen to the show on the app all of
that really awesome stuff finally we're
still waiting on Apple they they're very
serious about security and all that
stuff so you know I can respect it
they're they're uh it's gonna take a
little bit longer for the iPhone app to
come out but uh Android is currently
available also you'll see the link to
the timcast IRL in Miami event the
red-headed libertarian Josie will be
co-hosting a pre-show so definitely pick
up your tickets right now what do we got
left we've got 690 tickets remaining and
we just announced this last Thursday I
think it was so it's been just about a
week and we're already looking like we
sold maybe 150 so it'll probably uh you
may have some time I'm not going to act
like you know they're flying off the
shelves the first event we did sold out
I think in like a day or two that was
down in Austin this is going to be in
Miami with Patrick Bet David Donald
Trump Jr Matt Gates uh Luke gradkowski
and I will be coasting and of course Ian
will be with us as well hell yeah it's
gonna be a whole lot of fun we hope to
see you there there's a pre-show and
there's going to be an after show for
those that are in the audience we will
be live streaming but we will only live
stream the core portions of the pre-show
will not be live and the after show for
the audience with q a will also just be
for the event only but check that out at
timcast.com smash that like button
ladies and gentlemen subscribe to this
channel share the show uh it really is
the best way to help I'm looking at you
know all of these different shows I'm
like how do you succeed and the reality
is we've never run ads on this stuff
ever it really is just because of word
of mouth and organic reach so thank you
all so much you guys have been the main
reason that we exist where we are today
so uh consider sharing the show take
that URL post it wherever if you really
do like what we do joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Joshua Smith hey thanks so much for
having me Tim I appreciate it who are
you I'm a candidate for president of the
United States of America for the
libertarian party some are calling me
the preeminent candidate I've been an
at-large and vice chair on the
libertarian National Committee uh since
2018 and one form or another uh came
from the Ron Paul revolution in 2008
worked on his campaign and then he of
course endorsed me famously in 2020 for
chair of the libertarian National
Committee so wow that's where I'm at it
was the pitiful of my life next to my
children are you gonna have Michael
malice be your press secretary I I have
said that I will force him by court
order if need be so yeah because Dave
Dave's not gonna do it so you know
whoever does has to get Michael malice
to be the press secretary has to happen
I agree I agree he's there's nobody
better for it absolutely right on manual
should be a lot of fun thanks for
hanging out yeah of course Phil's back
hello everybody my name is Phil Avanti
lead singer of All That Remains
anti-communist encounter revolutionary
Destroyer it looks like you put on a
hell of a show last weekend you know I
uh I did I I had a little bit of an
event my friend's band called me up the
band's called The Five Finger Death
Punch uh Ivan their singer was uh ill
and so they called me and asked me if I
could fill in for them they were opening
for a small being called Metallica
and it was sick dude was in the round
you guys shot in that huge Stadium 80
000 people is it more than more than uh
Taylor Swift yeah more than two I mean
it's Metallica yeah obviously the
biggest metal band of all time and you
got to open yeah whipping your body
around like a rubber like a rubber hose
dude I mean it was super like it's super
cool that like I am able to help out my
friends like the guys in Five Finger
Death Punch I've been friends with those
guys for years and years I've known Ivan
since he was in mode grader in 2004 uh
we did some touring so I've known those
guys for ages so it's super cool that
like I can go ahead and step in and help
them out and and make sure that the show
goes on because you know it was a
record-breaking show it was a big deal
like they made history it was the
biggest show that ever happened at the
place and I got to come in and I look
like this you know like the the guy that
comes in to save the day so if they
haven't seen it there's Clips on your
Twitter and on Instagram it is wild man
there will be a bigger video coming
because uh five finger had like Pro
footage and stuff so we're getting that
wow great to meet you Josh I'm looking
forward to talking about politics
tonight yeah I want to Echo the timcast
IRL event in Miami which I'll be at
we'll be on stage and it we had so much
fun in Austin last time talking to
people after the show too I got a chance
to stick around and meet people so if
you guys ever want to get out to one of
these shows this Miami show is going to
be lit come on down man and Miami's
already lit did it and we are we are
planning an elite members only uh get
together so that's for the elite members
at timcast.com there's no VIP tickets
but it's basically if you're a Tim cast
member at 100 bucks or more you're in
the elite criteria which is access to
like early release stuff internals like
we just tell you what's going on we do
uh we we give people access to like the
app before it comes out we're probably
gonna be releasing the code for the
video game to our Elite members to just
do whatever they want with and so it's
kind of just like a club but we're gonna
have a special event for our Elite
members I think the best place to get
tickets is at timcast.com up at the top
there's a banner and I don't know if
there's another direct link but that's
how you get it so hit it right on we got
Kellen pressing the buttons yes I'm back
my name is Kellen and yeah dude October
Miami in October what I feel like that's
one of the best times to be there so it
should be a lot of fun buy your tickets
come down see Ian on the beach you know
that's where he'll be it's gonna be fun
shirtless all right let's jump into the
news Tucker Carlson predicts hot war
with Russia to defeat Trump in election
he was speaking to Adam Carolla and he
said they will do anything to win so how
do they do that they're not going to do
covet again whoever on the right is
afraid they're going to do covet and
mass mandates they're not going to do
that Carlson told Adam Carolla they
can't do that they've already been
exposed that won't work there's going to
be no what are they going to do they're
going to go to war with Russia it's what
they're going to do there will be a hot
war between the United States and Russia
in the next year
yikes that's uh strong words coming from
Tucker and it is a contrast to what
we've talked about what many have said
because we are seeing Mass mandates come
back yes however
he may be right
the covet game is played I think I agree
with them there that it's just it's
going to be with us forever now it's
going to be mutating and it's you're
going to have lesser dangerous strains
lesser painful ones and then every once
in a while one will mutate that's like
kind of hard but there will be like oh
no but it's like the flu and that's the
question the question is will they try
to use it for political thinking about
the thing Tucker he when I watched an
interview Donald Trump last week I don't
know if you guys saw the interview at
the very end he's like so do you think
there's going to be civil unrest and
he's doing that Sullivan not where he's
nodding and I'm like geez what is he
trying to incite like and Trump is just
like I don't I don't want to even answer
that like you could tell and Tucker's
like civil unrest and he's nodding like
I don't just why is he
I don't know why he said that I don't
know what that that we're going to war
with Russia I don't know why he said
that well for one is it the fact that
there's a war in Ukraine and we're
funding
Russia already that's not formalized so
he thinks I mean let me let me let me
let me help you out let me clarify
let me help you out I'll clarify for
Tucker Carlson they're not going to war
with Russia he's wrong what he should
have said is they're going to formally
announce we have been at war with Russia
and try and act like it's just begun I'm
concerned about Total War I can
understand the proxy war like Vietnam we
thought the Communists in Vietnam we
didn't want to bomb Moscow because we
don't know Washington to get wiped off
the map and if we go to war with Russia
we're going to annihilate our each of us
and then China will take over the world
like what or India and China will take
it over slow down there we're at war
with Russia right now it we already are
and so what do you guys think will
happen uh in the election cycle well
they're definitely going to bring the
the kovitz coming back I mean I I don't
know I mean I already see people talking
about Mass mandates at school at schools
um they're they're definitely going to
start Joe Biden's talking about a new uh
vaccine yes to be funded a whole new one
that's gonna work this time he says and
uh yeah weird thing to say and it's
inappropriate mind you yeah yes
inappropriate for Joe Biden to say that
I mean it actually is I don't think Joe
Biden cares what's inappropriate at this
point I I honestly think that Joe Biden
is like a smoker kid right he's much
like Weekend at Bernie's right now and
someone's holding him up with strings
and walking them around the stage I
honestly I don't know I I think that
they're gonna they're gonna try to push
the the mandates back I think they're
gonna try to mess with people's jobs
again I really do and I I but I think
that you know the American public many
of the people who fell for it first time
are not going to fall forward again but
so so the way we've described it is
or what we've predicted
they will issue guidelines they'll do
something like you cannot discriminate
against someone who seeks who decides to
quarantine but no one's forced to
quarantine but then businesses will need
money to pay for employees who don't
want to come into work and don't have to
then they'll issue another kind of PPP
or whatever the guidelines because they
know they can't do a hard lockdown
justify an expansion of universal
mail-in voting I wouldn't be surprised
if they outright legalize Mass ballot
harvesting under the guise of covet
there's no doubt that that's that's part
of this push I mean they definitely want
they want mail-in voting as much as
possible look the Democrats the
Democrats are going to do anything they
possibly can to win uh I just don't
think they can do it with Biden but but
covet is not out of the realm of
possibility to force this election to be
done through melon voting I don't think
that we're in we're not talking in a
vacuum right now millions of people are
listening to us and if we make enough
noise ahead of time and shock people out
of the stupor they won't we won't even
get off the ground we have agreed I
spent two two full years rallying
against the stuff I'm my smaller podcast
and and you definitely the big
podcasters the big shows have got to
push this uh you know Mass it was uh I
think Scott Adams Scott Adams said the
first company to do this we must
bankrupt yes absolutely stop buying all
their products and and Bud Light and
Target them in the exact same way I read
that van Gardens and uh and BlackRock
are getting out of ESG they're down to
like three percent yeah but that just
means that they're looking for another
thing to call they're finding something
else yeah absolutely interesting they're
not gonna give up on the goal no right
so and that's something that that people
on the right and people that are
involved in in you know whatever you
want to call it the culture or whatever
you need to understand like even if like
BlackRock and Vanguard and all these
these um investment bankers and stuff
they they get out of the ESG uh model
they're going to be looking for
something else to achieve the same goals
because they're ideologically modeled
well you made a good point there with
the with the fact that um they're not
gonna they're not gonna change the goal
the goal is always going to stay the
same and that's what what worries me
about the Russia thing right is that if
kova doesn't work there's a damn good
chance that they use a hot one what do
you think is the goal with Russia
the goal with Russia right now I
honestly I think that it's to push them
towards the the One World Government I
mean if you want to get really deep into
Alex Jones
there are there are two dominant Global
factions yeah NATO and Bricks sure
what's the what's the idea we need to
crush them because bricks is our enemy
no
I don't you're not gonna you're not
gonna get Russia to fall under NATO
influence right because they're they're
they're not going to they just want we
rushing every week
right right I think it may actually just
be more so
they're not thinking about it in terms
of we must defeat Russia because
Russia's enemy it's we must reduce
Bricks by seven percent sure yeah sure
and there's seven percent of the
population I mean seven Russia's like
seven percent is the people calling
shots are like and if we reduce the
United States Power by 20 in order to
reduce Russia by seven percent then the
Swiss Bankers win right but we've talked
about this though there's there's a lot
of in my opinion there's substance of
the argument that the established you
know order right now is changing the
holy City's traffic that we talk about
and it seems to me and I've heard the
argument I forget where I heard it but
I'd see but it seems reasonable to me
that the goal of the people that are
like in the wef and stuff like that um
and the UN stuff the goal is to
do a soft Landing with the United States
as China Rises and the intent is in this
is to keep the whole world out of World
War III but if they can have a soft
landing and lower the u.s's
um living standards in a way that
doesn't cause too much chaos in the
United States and also at the same time
support China so they can raise their
their level of of influence and stuff
and manage that without having the US
and trying to go to war that I think is
the goal because the the the Chinese
model in my opinion is what the people
like the wef and stuff was what they
want to Institute in the west because
they have essentially ultimate control
over the population have you have you
guys seen that uh Eugenia Cooney video
she's the uh yeah social media
influencer who weighs probably 13 pounds
literally maybe like 40 pounds yeah and
uh like on the verge of death anorexic
right and and she's apparently got like
like 8 million hits on Tick Tock people
are begging her to get help and all that
stuff but it just it reminds me of what
the war actually is right now you have
influence from China to destroy the
younger Generations in this country
these kids I saw one story already
someone said that their younger sibling
stopped eating because they wanted to
look like Eugenia it's the it's the
Opium works if they're not using actual
physical opium they're using technology
they are though I mean that's coming to
the southern part so that's happening
too yeah does China want to destroy
America you think that China wants to
destroy America or they just want to
weaken it so they can have ten we get 10
more power I I think right now what the
the global powers are looking at is I
just want them to be weaker than us so
we have the dominant position it's
almost like a Sumo match right but it
could eventually lead to a fist fight
and it seems like that's where we're
going now as for Tucker Carlson
predicting hot war with Russia I think
it's funny because if you actually talk
to him about it and said right but we're
at war with Russia he'd say well yes of
course of course yeah and then he'd
expand upon the idea the idea being the
U.S will formally declare war or they'll
find a reason to do it and uh uh it's
it's going to be some kind of false flag
not with Congress though of course not
it's gonna it's gonna be unilateral it's
going to be it's going to be a NATO uh
NATO uh Article Five sure so false like
this is what they did in Vietnam they
did a false flag to get us to go to
Vietnam to fight a proxy war against
Russia right uh so you're thinking now
they're going to do a false flag to get
us go fight the mainland Russia like yo
we're going to invade Russia I know
there's I the idea of the United States
putting boots into like Russia no what
about not on Alaska I mean it's what is
it like 100 miles away from Russia no
there's not even up there 50 miles or so
there's nothing
the Aleutian Islands stretch all the way
like very very close to Japan but think
about listen think about what you're
talking about though like if if Russia
invades Alaska right they have to go
over the Rockies to get to Mainland to
the lower 48. or they have to invite
Canada yeah they have to go through
Canada and they have to go over like
this is not they're going to be slipping
on maple syrup yeah
listen I've I've traveled through the
Rockies out there you blow up passes and
you shut down any advance okay you can't
drive tanks and stuff like that through
the mountains without roads that's
that's just not happening it is not
happening like what about three on the
flip side China invades Alaska for
resources
you can take all of Alaska yeah yeah but
I mean I mean how many people are are in
Alaska there's like 250 000 in the state
I think we'd have no choice but to
respond with a maximum military force oh
yeah if there's an invasion I don't I
don't I don't think there's no waiting
around I decimate the opponent in that
situation maybe not invade I think to
let's get let's get specific in the
event that China Russia or whatever
these these brics Powers invade Alaska
that's a long shot for a variety of
reasons but they do I do not believe
that
um ICBM nuclear weapons will be launched
over that however don't be surprised if
you see
nuclear artillery yeah you know to be
honest with you like not that I not that
this the idea of anyone invading Alaska
is more compelling now that we're
discussing it but if there were a
situation like that Alaska is the type
of place where using uh tactical nuclear
weapons uh would make sense there's
nobody around very small population yeah
there's nobody around and if you if you
see a column moving you know take them
out offensive like counter offense
tactical nuclear weapons like on Russian
cities the Russians in those days the
United States
but hold on this is the problem with
nukes the Russian government attacks so
your response is to vaporize a million
innocent civilians right right we can't
do that and that's why I don't think the
nukes go flying this this idea that in
the event of War we all start firing
nukes at our at our at our cities is
just like
they're trying to control the cities
they're trying to control resources
nobody wants to I would say for the most
part most people don't want to rule over
the ashes but they don't want to be
subjugated either the only reason you
would see nukes fly is to destroy
military targets so you may see New York
in some way devastated by a massive
nuclear attack or some kind of advanced
attack I believe it's more likely at
this point civilian targets will be hit
by Massive cyber attacks what we saw
with the ransomware where you have like
these the the train system the whole
network goes down because all the
computers get encrypted instantly the
pipeline
exactly how did they take out nordstream
how did U.S intelligence and Western
Powers take out in order
conventional explosives a lot of Nano
thermites a lot of explosives like again
apparently the uh it's not that hard the
pipeline was like encased and kind of
like it's not just like a tube like it's
a big deal right so there's a lot of uh
look you don't it's underwater you blow
it up yeah you don't need a nuclear bomb
to blow up a pipe right but what I what
I think we'd be more likely to see is um
Callum mentioned it there was that Cyber
attack on that uh that that Pipeline and
that basically shut down gas supply in
in the Southeast and people don't
remember that it's kind of like yo that
could be War yeah and you would not know
the the risk is
in the past Gulf of tank and Vietnam the
U.S wanted the American people to think
we were attacked to justify public
support for a war right today there's
good reason not to get forced into war
because you want to be prepared for one
and if you're not you don't want your
economy disrupted so the US is not going
to come out and be like that Cyber
attack that was China because that would
mean the people would rally and demand
retaliation which we may not be prepared
for however that being said the US
government could very easily
Cyber attack a water plant or a pipeline
disrupt the flow of energy in you know
the Midwest in Chicago or something
millions of people are in Desperate
Panic water is not pumping out of their
you know there's no electricity or
whatever and then they say
that was China we found Putin's passport
I like that I like that line of thinking
because we're listen we us podcasters
and guys who do shows we're constantly
talking about who's our biggest enemy
who's our biggest these guys are These
Guys these guys are gonna attack
thermonuclear war are our biggest
enemies right here man you know what I
mean like the the American government
can do whatever they want they could
shut off our resources I mean it's it's
pretty you know it's pretty scary to
think about what they could do to us we
have a correction John uh John Curry
says Phil there's over 700 000 people in
Alaska the chat is upset they're mad at
you I apologize
you're an Alaska bigot and the thing is
there's a lot of people in the chat that
we're saying they're like
736 081 as of 2020. so probably more at
this point median household income 77
800 yeah they're not that ain't bad
they're not doing bad well they also
they get the oil subsidies yeah but it's
only like a couple Grand I heard per
month or I know a few of them get a
couple Grand I thought it was a couple
Grand a month I don't know maybe I've
never I've been to Alaska that's
basically the median income I've been to
Alaska once don't take don't take don't
take my word for it I know that it was
it used to it goes up and down I know
let's let's bring it back home you're
talking about you know the the enemy's
domestic well let's talk about what's
happening here in the US we got this
story from the Daily Mail Tucker Carlson
claims Barack Obama enjoyed smoking
crack and having gay sex nobody reported
ahead of the 2008 election did he
actually claim it or did he say maybe
this is no he said outright yes how does
he know he said that the campaign would
remove anybody who brought it up in 2008
even because he said a guy came forward
Larry Sinclair and said I'll sign an
affidavit and he did I'll do a lie
detector and he did he said that he
smoked crack with Barack Obama and they
had sex that was obviously true Carlson
was referencing the claims made by a
convicted felon Sinclair at the national
Press Club in 2008 while Obama was
running for president he said nobody
reported on it due to threats from the
Obama campaign quote nobody reported it
not because they were squeamish about
sex or drugs but because the Obama
campaign said anyone who reports on this
gets no access to the Obama campaign so
they didn't report on it the amount of
lying in the media about it was
unbelievable this happens all the time
up and down government Sinclair who has
spent time in prison for forgery fraud
and larceny alleged that Obama who was
then a senator bought and smoked cocaine
I think it was crack before having sex
with him well I will I will add that um
Obama has not particularly good taste in
men if that's true
well you know I mean and he has good
taste in women
well look I mean yeah I gotta be honest
like if you if you put Michelle Obama
next to this guy she's got beautiful
eyes
let's be real I mean this is this guy's
54 now and he was a lot younger back
then uh but let's be serious there was
that letter they actually have it they
have something here on the story look at
this I don't know what this is they say
former president Barack Obama's gay sex
fantasy was revealed in a newly obtained
1982 letter to his ex-girlfriend so we
know in 1982 yeah he was 21 I think he
was writing about how he wanted to bang
dudes and you know hey more power to him
man I just think it's historically
significant if we can if we can say that
um Barack Obama not only uh the first
black president uh or not entirely white
president was also a gay man who smoked
crack one more reason to give the guy to
give the guy grief he was the first LGBT
president yeah and didn't even have the
cojones to admit it don't be big and he
lied he lied when he was running he was
against gay marriage when he was running
again and then he came out uh once he
got elected so he lies to get elected
hides the fact that he's LGBT and then
he comes out oh God more reason to hate
on him thanks Obama I don't think
Tucker's lying but I don't think that
taking the word of a fraudster this
guy's a convicted convicted for fraud
and he's the one that's saying that he
had sex with Barack I it's witness
testimony it's one guy's testimony so
why would Tucker make the claim that
it's true
exactly not admissible in court yet
Tucker claims it's true because the guys
because it makes good headlines Tucker's
saying what he Tucker's reporting what
he heard well he's he could have said
that a guy told him but instead he came
out and said it's true I don't know I
mean I didn't did he actually say it's
true so I mean maybe maybe this could
confirm the the Big Mike rumors though
I don't know if that I don't know lie
detectors can be admissible as long as
both parties agree to them okay the
issue is more so that there someone will
contest it so they're generally not used
but even still I mean it doesn't it
doesn't matter like the people that
don't like Barack Obama this is only
going to be stuff for them to go ahead
and make jokes about the people that
like Barack Obama they're not going to
care it doesn't matter
we know we know that he would lie about
you know his policies to get elected I
mean that's that's he's we already know
what kind of person he is he's already
in and out of office he's already killed
yeah children that's the thing if you
really want to stay focused on what he's
done wrong I feel like this is a red
herring there's no reason well nobody's
focusing on what he's done wrong there's
absolutely no appetite to bring him up
on charges for anything so there's no
point other than being like hey don't
forget if news does come out for some
reason it sticks and it's like Barack
Obama killed American citizen nobody
cares but let's say for some reason the
story does pop whatever a new one comes
out that Obama mentioned another drone
strike Obama would come out and all the
news would be like Obama's about to give
a press conference oh I wonder if it's
about the allegations and the drones and
he's gonna go my fellow Americans I'm
gay and then that's it and then
everyone's like goes wild yeah
yep that I mean that's the thing for me
it's like it's it's it's funny you know
if you want them to to make jokes about
or whatever like you know poke fun at it
to to make light of it but it's not
substantially it doesn't matter it's fun
on the internet yeah exactly it's
exactly it's a funny meme it's fun on
the internet and we were talking about
this before listen if you're involved in
politics but you're not taking part in
the culture where you're dead in the
water right we talked about that on the
way here every single you know candidate
for anything Pete bootage anybody who's
got uh some kind of diverse uh identity
of any sort is gonna put that at the
very Forefront to deflect them from all
their bad policies and Obama would just
do that he'd write another Memoir you
know and everybody to go buy it and
forget all about it I don't know but I
do think things are changing right that
that's uh statistic about 12 seconds
12th grade boys being uh or males
they're adults
um skewing conservative yeah I actually
as you mentioned if you're not in the
culture where you're not in politics
exactly yeah I think we're we're we're
at heavy Market saturation for politics
it's it's becoming pop culture I mean
we've talked about this a couple years
ago politics is pop culture that's why
you get people who have no business in
politics doing political podcasts this
is why you have late night comedy it's
nothing but politics right there's no
one cares about anything else speaking
of did you see the five bit the big five
night late night hosts Strike Force Five
dude they're doing a Twitter show
together and it looks so lame
Seth uh what's his name Seth something
Myers Myers looked so miserable in that
promo it's like you couldn't even say it
with feeling I saw the clip and now I
have to start chemoing what's okay it's
got Jimmy and Jimmy Fallon looks so
annoyed with Jimmy Kimmel like those
guys do not want to be in the same room
together he's like oh my God I'm stuck
up they're getting paid 100 million
bucks tonight or whatever contract and
the studios were like you're doing we
know how to make money and generate
contact while their content while
there's no writers you're doing this
they made Stephen Colbert be like the
ringleader and the other guy's like who
is this dip like I'm not bowing down to
this guy why is he the one ring-leading
this crap it's really annoying I
breaking apart
I hope so I mean Joe Joe Rogan being the
biggest podcast is and and for a long
time and by a long shot I mean a long
long ways I mean he's got what Twice The
Daily viewership as CNN I mean it's long
form one-on-one yes it's the most bomb
awesome agree possible format yeah you
might be bringing other people too is
cool but any disruption of a Vibe sucks
if you're really in the zone Tucker
proved it I mean he went he went free
agent and he's getting more views than
fox has ever got ever ever you learn so
much about somebody and let's be real
right so everyone's talking about this
200 million views or whatever those are
tweet views Impressions yeah I don't
like the word impression because
typically an impression implies like
when you're scrolling through an article
and there's something on the left of the
screen you don't pay attention to right
a tweet view passes by you and you look
at it as it passes you by
so it's I'm not trying to to defend you
know Impressions or whatever I'm just
trying to point out there is a subtle
difference if I'm scrolling my Twitter
feed and I'm actually looking at things
and then not interested not interested
not interested it's very different to an
ad was on the left of my screen I never
even noticed do you know how long it
needs to remain on your screen as you're
scrolling to count it might be a couple
seconds that would be in the code I
think it's three seconds okay it's
different on different sizes I'm not
entirely sure but what we do know is if
you actually look at the Hard numbers
which are available on some devices it
was around like 20 million views sure
and you look at his ratings on Fox they
they come out like Tucker did not get
200 million views he got 20 and I'm like
Wow when he was on Fox who's getting
three right so now he's getting 17 more
okay you look at all the shows he's
doing he actually is getting several
million hits per episode yeah no I mean
I'm sure he's getting a lot more
especially with the president Trump
interview way more than he ever got on
Fox I mean it can't be even close well
he had like five point something was his
record you know yeah
with the Trump thing it's it was like
20. yeah it was uh I think when they
reported it was around like 18 so it's
got to be
20 to 25 by now well and I could say if
actual like people sitting down and
watching through the video listen I this
is as a as a candidate for president I I
am not and I mean I'm not out seeking
the Legacy like corporate news media I'm
seeking the big podcasters right that's
who I wanna that's who I want to go to
when you have candidates for the office
of the of the entire United States
executive branch that are seeking out
podcasts instead of the the corporate
news media the corporate news meet is
dead that's it dude this is what vivek's
plan has been too Rachel maddow's
audience elderly right and uh even even
Fox News audience they're they're a lot
older Tucker here's here's the biggest
screw-up that fox did Tucker actually
was attracting younger viewers yes he
was getting key demo viewers you look at
these other guys and they're and they're
skewing way older and that's it
they walked away from all of it yeah
what have they got left Greg got Phil
does he that's about I mean God feels
cool he's doing he's doing well he's a
younger crowd Jesse Waters took over for
Tucker but everybody just despises Fox
News I mean you look at uh um who was it
was it uh Neil Cavuto talking to Vivek
ramaswamy trying to justify the
indictments against Trump and it's it's
just laughably bad and Vivek is like no
are you nuts he's like well you know
there's all of these indictments I mean
one of them has to be real and it's like
are you kidding me the fox is terrible
but you know to be honest Cavuto is
never like their best personality anyway
right I haven't watched Fox other than
Tucker Gutfeld and Kennedy I haven't
watched fox in probably I don't know 10
years Kennedy's awesome yeah I used to
watch her on MTV man so did I that girl
was awesome yeah plus uh she'd have
Devon Dave was like a regular and Spike
Spike's been up there several times too
Olivia Rondo goes on yeah Olivia Rondo
there's a lot of people that I I know
from the conservative Circle that goes
on there what's your plan man your
presidential plan uh so we we actually
we have a whole website has all our
platforms up there abolished yeah so we
I've talked about so you know much like
vivec who I think may have stolen one of
my platform points but by the way I'm
pretty sure that he stole one uh for the
debate I had never heard a presidential
candidate talk about how the federal
government subsidizes separating
families and States uh until he's he
spoke about it on the on the debate but
I do want to abolish title IV D of the
Social Security Act which is a incentive
from the federal government they give
three dollars for every two dollars
spent on child support and enforcement
programs in every state so they're
incentivizing the state to create a
visitor out of one parent
and uh because custodian apparent out of
the other parent and then if this parent
has any issues they criminalize them and
take more so we're talking three dollars
for every two dollars given that's what
they do
um and if you look since 1975 when when
Ford signed this into law uh if you look
since then the um uh amount of
fatherless homes has increased tenfold
tenfold I mean insane amount and one in
four uh kids lives and father's home now
let's talk uh let's talk politics we're
talking about uh you know we've been
talking about enemies both foreign and
domestic and we have this story Donald
Trump tells Glenn Beck you have no
choice he will absolutely lock people up
if returned to the White House he didn't
say it with much enthusiasm but uh
here's the clip for all of you
and in you know uh lock her up and then
when you became president you said we
don't do that in America that's just not
the right thing to do that's what
they're doing do you regret not locking
her up and if your president again will
you lock people up
well I'll give you an example uh the
answer is you have no choice because
they're doing it to us I always had such
great respect for the Office of the
President the presidency and but the
Office of the President and I never hit
Biden as hard as I could have
and then I heard he was trying to indict
me and it was him that was doing it you
know I don't think he's sharp enough to
think about much but he was there and he
was probably the one Glenn Beck's life
he was you know hard to believe that he
even thinks about that because he's he's
gone but then I said well they're
actually trying to indict me because
every one of these indictments is him
including brag you know Bragg put his he
put his time so he got it he says he's
going to lock people up what I want to
add to this is Rachel Maddow recently
said that Donald Trump is only running
because he wants to solve his legal
problems that's actually Joe Biden right
and now that Joe Biden is president he's
probably saying all I can do is either
win re-election or lock Trump up but if
Trump wins I'm going down and of course
you have to accuse your opponents of
doing what you in fact are doing so
Rachel Maddow comes out blames Trump
says he wants to be president for life I
guess the question is one do you really
think Trump will do this and then after
we answer that my question for you
Joshua is uh are you also going to lock
people up uh yeah I I definitely want to
investigate the coveted regime and about
you a fouchy safer uh any gov any
Governor yes because yes you know I feel
like saying just the covid regime does
it go far enough yes yes
there's definitely there's definitely
people that need to be locked don't let
them turn you to the dark side yes uh no
they won't um no the light is trying to
to save there is criminals there is
nothing Divine fire there is nothing
illiberal about enforcing the law
no because if it's if it's if you have a
liberal Society especially a society
like ours that protects the people
protects rights your laws should not be
violating people's rights not without
due process so if you've got someone
that has has been using the government
the federal government to enrich their
own family there's nothing immoral about
it about enforcing like enforcing the
law or investigating it this earlier
today I I've tweeted there's currently a
member of an amount of circumstantial
evidence Joe Biden is engaged in pay for
influence in Ukraine via his son the
president of the United States Donald
Trump was impeached by the Democrats for
investigating this like that's actually
what happened like there is no reason
why we shouldn't investigate the entire
Biden Administration the whole
administration his family like all of
his business associations they know it
who's gonna who's gonna force that
investigation though well I mean that's
that I'm saying that that would be if
Trump were to be here's the big question
do you actually think Trump is going to
do anything
uh no it's not I don't think it's a
matter of where Trump will want to I
think it's a matter of whether Trump
will be able to successfully execute
because it's a matter of can he find
people in government that are or that
could fulfill the roles that are
competent that will be able to get into
positions in the bureaucracy and
actually process investigate and
prosecute will they be able because you
know that they're going to be people in
FBI and CIA and stuff like that that are
going to be doing all they can to hide
stuff so it's a matter of will he be
able to get people that are effective
will he want to I think he'll want to
will he execute
who knows this is a
we we just heard that Enrique tario's
sentencing was delayed because the judge
fell ill it was an emergency and they're
trying to lock up Enrique and other
members of The Proud boys for 33 years
ridiculous Donald Trump gets elected
these men are pardoned
there there should be I I believe Trump
pardons them everybody everybody that
like everybody on January 6th in my like
even the people that were getting into
fights with cops they've already done
their time they've already done enough
time now consider let them go
if we are talking about
Civil War everybody drink oh here we go
yeah uh you have these individuals being
accused and and convicted of seditious
conspiracy quite literally they were
accused of a plot to overthrow the
United States in support of Donald Trump
the argument being brought forward by
the Democrats is that Trump was their
leader who actually wanted them and
encouraged them to do this
if Trump gets elected
how will the view of the left not be
Donald Trump succeeded in overthrowing
the United States government that will
be the narrative it will be shoved down
people's throat and every single like
you know
wine mom is going to buy it so how could
any of these liberals or leftists argue
we are not in a civil war if they
believe that proud boys were engaged in
a seditious conspiracy at the direction
of Donald Trump to overthrow the United
States and Donald Trump still has a path
to gain power in fact they believe he
currently is likely to win
I think that will be the narrative I
mean there's there's no doubt about it
that's going to be the narrative
everyone runs with it especially if he
wins do do you honestly think that he
will uh pardon Enrique though yes you do
I I I'm not saying it's 100 sure but I
think um we've already got I'm not your
buddy guy in the Super Chat saying
Robert Barnes for A.G I'm I'm wondering
if
Trump plays the tepid role and just wins
and goes ah we gotta slow down blah blah
or does Trump go in and say at this
point I am done and then he Robert
Barnes he starts bringing in Die Hard
Trump supporters to do these jobs who
will do without question because he did
not do that the first time he went to
his donors he went to the establishment
and said you know who do you think would
be good let's play ball and then they
tried to destroy him and he walked he He
Walked the Line there there you've
you've got these false charges
accusations of being a Russian spy
you've got the you know he tries to dig
into the Ukraine Scandal and they
impeach him over it and what does he do
nothing right so I'm not entirely
convinced but I do think there's a
possibility that if Trump is elected
it's revenge and then you'll see Maga
personalities I mean look look at
Jeffrey Clark
acting Assistant Attorney General and
they've criminally indicted him if Trump
brings that guy back I imagine he's
going to be like I can't imagine because
we've had Jeffrey Clark here I can't
imagine he's the kind of guy who's gonna
be like I want revenge no he's going to
be the guy who says yo these people are
corrupt and if we're gonna save this
country they must be criminally charged
Joshua I I have a question how many and
what departments would you abolish
there's not enough time on the show no
no it's easier to ask which departments
which ones will you leave thank you I
appreciate that which ones would you
leave not I can't even think of any
right now I know that we're going after
the ATF first I I believe 100 and Vivek
talked a lot about this that you can't
actually the president doesn't actually
have the power to go and abolish some of
these things like on his own no but you
you The Vape mentioned like Mass layoffs
it's not about layoffs it's about
organizational RFI as well where you can
transfer right and stuff like that it's
like when you when you when you're a
boss at a company and you know you can't
fire someone so you put them in the
Janitor's Closet hope they quit my goal
is to get rid of everybody at the ATF
and then uh level level the ATF building
and turn it into a dog park I'd auction
off all the uh leftover ATF equipment no
no no no no no no I I I absolutely I can
pay uh that we can pay reparations to
people who had it unconstitutionally buy
NFA tax stamps I am I am uh I am
offended by this notion I reject this
notion the ATF building should be turned
into large gun super malls that would be
good too yes that's that's a we can do
we can do both with a different
buildings but I think in honor of all
the dogs murdered you know I know so
much
I have I have a friendly relationship
with the people at Brownells and I
wonder if they want a new location in
Washington DC
yeah oh there you go apparently they're
up there too absolutely no I I can't
think of many I can't think of an agency
that I'd keep keep right now yeah I'm
trying I'm like I had a really good
conversation with Austin Peterson
I I had a good conversation about the
CIA but maybe the Department of
Transportation like well Department of
energy is the one I'm thinking of cars
cars yeah but if we're trying to manage
Interstate Rail and and freight and
stuff it it might might make sense I
mean I'm not saying it does to have some
kind of organizing body for so it's
easier for California to adjudicate you
know
between other states if like Wyoming has
got an issue and then I guess the courts
could handle that well I don't think I
know the IRS is gone right away oh yeah
the first one out the door and I would
like to abolish the income tax entirely
that includes the state tax payroll tax
and capital gains tax how do people not
vote for this and then and then I want
to Institute what's user fees which is
what the federal government always
should have been user fees if you use if
listen if you're an American paying the
federal government you don't need
anything from the federal government
there's no reason you should be paying
the federal government period plain and
stuff so like what if you want to drive
on an interstate highways toll so if
there yeah if there's a Fed yeah maybe
maybe we go to some kind of toll system
too but there's already a lot of toll
booths for a lot of different
interstates around the country but user
fees and and it would be a while like
there's yeah people forget that there is
the tax there's a federal tax in every
gallon of gas that is sold and the
reason that there is a federal tax the
what sold people on it was tax is going
to be used to pay for the highways so
you've got the federal government taxing
every gallon of gas they have plenty of
money
that's the problem is that all these
bills reports with are pork packed with
pork and and they're paying for pet
projects I mean it comes out of Social
Security it comes out of the gas tax it
comes out but the point is we don't need
to have an income tax for a lot of the
things that people think we need the
income tax for and also we are on we are
our government works with a modern
monetary policy basic Theory so they're
they don't really care about collecting
taxes to pay for anything if they want
something they print the money to pay to
make it and then they just collect taxes
to reduce inflation just really quickly
to add your point and uh I don't know
how many people watching know this but
prior to the National Tax Act and even
the 16th Amendment there was uh there
there was still a government that
operated before they stole it that's not
true straight from your paycheck yeah
absolutely and this is a story they tell
kids it's scary you know if you want
National Defense or whatever I mean
listen any patriotic American that likes
their National Defense System if you
told them we're not going to take your
payroll taxes anymore but would you be
willing to voluntarily crowdfund our
national military with 10 bucks a month
I guarantee there's a millions of people
are going to pay for that everything I
got an idea we talked about this with a
fake
um if you want to vote you have to sign
up for the draft
that's uh there's a lot of theories like
that sign up for the draft there's also
uh if you want to vote you should be a
property owner a landowner I don't know
if you've heard that one floating around
yeah the the I don't agree with that
because uh
we're we're in an era of renting which
didn't exist back in the day it made
sense back in the day it's like hey if
you live here you can vote on what we're
doing but if you don't live here why are
you voting on what we're doing you don't
live here now it's like well I do live
here I rent a room upstairs I'm an
anti-draft so I don't think that I'm
inscription so let me ask you though if
uh let's say that the the uh
all these apartments are about you get
elected president you walk in you you
start signing executive executive orders
so fast your your right arm is just
massive and we're going to yeah and
you've signed like 10 000 documents
you're drenched in sweat the rest of
your body is disheveled and Fallen
before like Joe Joe Biden to the normal
after all of that
a Utopia a Libertarian Utopia exists and
then China invades California with a
massive force of 300 000 troops and they
start just gunning down and massacring
people and at that point do you say we
need a draft we need to get people to
come and fight no so so I wouldn't
listen if I got if you people were wild
enough to actually put me in the White
House okay let's say that first okay as
a Libertarian if if you guys are crazy
enough to come in the white house right
now I appreciate it I'm gonna do all the
work I possibly can to make sure that
people have more freedoms every day I'm
not in any place to immediately cut the
military that's just crazy bringing
troops home stopping Wars abroad closing
down some bases that we don't need
around the world I think that's an
important step and then a more
aggressive Mental Health Care policy for
our vets that are coming home from broad
that are need to reintegrate in with
their wives and families and stuff
because we haven't taken care of our
veterans in this country at all at all I
am a veteran
um but it's not like I'm going to come
in on day one and be like that's it all
military Terry's done you're all going
home I'm just saying in the hypothetical
scenario you're talking about an
anarchist Society no I'm just saying in
the hypothetical hypothetical scenario
that the United States is directly
invaded and we have multiple forces
storming our beaches and taking over our
cities you still oppose conscription uh
yes I would I would oppose conscription
and in fact I think that I think that
our uh you know our citizens are going
to do what the military would do on
their own for their own home and they'd
volunteer I think I think they're going
to take up arms I mean we have more guns
here in the United States that's why no
one's ever really invaded the United
States there's more guns here yeah but
also in the United States is real damn
big to invade yeah you look at you look
at like crossing the mountains would be
harder than Afghanistan for sure yeah I
mean it's it's just like like I was
saying earlier like getting through the
mountain ranges in the west coast like
people talk about oh well you know China
invading blah blah the Rockies will shut
down in advance
nothing Appalachia yeah and yeah
Appalachia would too I mean like the US
has has could you imagine
Great Lakes too in Russia or China
invading and they're trying to move
Westward through Appalachian there's a
bunch of they're done right-wing nut
jobs with the Barrett M82 is up on a
mountain they're picking them off one by
one I don't know if you would need to
Institute a draft to defend but if if
there's no military command overseeing
the logistics then it would just be
disparate factions I don't think I don't
think we're gonna get really the best
option if you're trying to defend I will
that's exactly what the Taliban yeah
they don't have a centralized thing
Taliban got whipped around for two
decades the town they took over in two
seconds you're not taught okay so like
you're not talking about individual
engagements individual engagements the
Taliban lose individual engagements the
Vietnamese lost but because of the
policy goal that the government's had
they were unattainable so even the
individual battles and engagements they
lose they're never going to achieve the
policy goals which is why rifles and a
determined enemy will always all always
beat an invading Army and I will say to
look up the Afghanistan papers if you
haven't I'm sure your crowd always knows
about that but the government knew knew
that that was an unwanted war in
Afghanistan 100 even at the very
beginning they had to do to defend was
the the Taliban was living in caves and
the Vietnamese were living underground
literally in Tunnels for 10 years
[Music]
what's the option it's our background
the option is you draft your neighbors
and you get organized with the military
it's an invasion yeah
defensive War I mean what that's what
the draft people are going to fight it
anyways here if they invade and they
take a beachhead and they take land
they're all the federal government is
already strapped if if if they if a a
foreign government a foreign military
actually manages to establish a
beachhead and and have the beginning of
an infrastructure to take mainland
United States the amount like the
government has to be in shambles by then
anyways for that to even become I I
disagree you don't think the federal
government Southern no well that's not
that's not that's fine
I'm talking about Landing crafts
I'm saying the federal government is
incapable of dealing with Perhaps it is
by Design but
I I I don't think
I think people overestimate the the the
capabilities of the United States I I
absolutely do they there are people who
have been saying over and over again for
years the federal government won't allow
this they won't allow that it's like how
many how many federal law enforcement
officers and and how many people are you
think are in the military
the military is somewhere around I'll
tell you this if I was a tyrant and I
was running this country as a tyrant and
I wanted to weaken this country to make
it submit one of the things I would do
is I would send all of my troops to over
200 bases around the country with the
world within the world yeah 200 bases
around the world and make it very easy
to invade this country do you think if
we sort of bring our troops home you'd
be as worried about
us having a war here in the United
States we're less worried if our troops
were at home yes absolutely 100 so bring
them home is is the important and good
and righteous thing but then there is
the argument of staging offensive
operations to prevent an attack the
United States I just I just want to
stress I really love the idea of
imagining what would it be like if a
foreign Invader came to Appalachia I do
it all the time it's so fun it's so fun
to imagine because when you go up to
like various mountains over here and we
know all the people live in these
mountains and they are they they
lovingly call themselves right-wing nut
jobs and then they have like guns
everywhere and I'm just saying there'll
be a guy up on a mountain with his
Barrett and he's going to be alike just
waiting it's like do you want to no
one's coming he's like I want to be here
in case they do I think the age of
ground invasion is kind of not really
over but like World War II they had to
drop nukes on Japan because they knew a
ground invasion of the of the island
would have been a Million Dead Americans
like you can't fight in entrenched Force
no it'd be insane for them to send
ground invasion in the United
so here's the first thing you get you'd
get cyber attacks which would cut off
your infrastructure you'd lose you'd
lose gasoline oil electricity goes out
then you'll get strategic drone strikes
after the infrastructure is just ripped
to shreds then you get the ground forces
coming in to secure the the territory
you cannot occupy a street corner with a
drone so after they decimate any kind of
infrastructure I mean really people need
to consider what it means if our oil uh
pipelines get shut down that's another
thing people don't realize there's only
a handful of places that actually refine
oil so like Jersey right outside of New
York City uh new or New Orleans and I
believe in La those are the three places
that you can import oil into the U.S and
if I understand correctly and I could be
wrong if I understand correctly that's
it you take those you take out those
cities or those refineries and the U.S
oil production I believe comes to comes
close to a standstill it's significantly
hurt Rachel Maddow had that famous line
where she's like Russia could shut up if
your electricity in the winter with a
Cyber attack it's like well what they
probably do is they'd probably just uh
destroy the North Dakota Frack Fields
yeah large amounts of energy produced in
these areas fossil fuels they'd shut
that down they'd have to come through
Canada to get there no they wouldn't
they'd go on their computer in Russia
and type a few lines of code and hit
enter and it goes down now that is
whether or not you believe that uh we
have defensive capabilities in our
infrastructure ten years ago we did not
we were running industrial Control
Systems from the 70s and of course I
guess the prevailing Theory or one of
them was that every major world power
had already gained a death grip on the
Cyber infrastructure of every other
country and at any minute mutually sure
destruction at that point was we press
enter and your electricity goes out and
it's not coming back and then the
response was yeah we'll do the same to
you because we have off Network machines
that are capable of shutting you down
mutually assured destruction everyone
thinks is nukes flying at this point
it's a guy pressing enter and look at
look at stuxnet remember that yeah that
was 10 years ago Iranian amazing they
were like release the virus and let it
go into the wild and eventually find its
way to the Iranian centrifuges and blow
them up they don't even need to do
anything on U.S soil whether Cyber
attack or Invasion canals the Suez and
Panama we're already seeing all the
packs of the Panama backup imagine like
we'll rely on all of our products all of
our lives are through China so what if
they stop all Transportation coming from
that way you know so I'm not even
worried about the US people you know
it's a really good argument for making
more things in America by the way
absolutely people really don't
understand and haven't taken a
consideration what would happen during a
war and we have not even ever scratched
the surface on what would happen you
know we were talking about Civil War the
other night
and uh I forgot who the guest was they
said peaceful divorce which I said is
absolutely impossible impossible but
peaceful divorce it's like a peaceful
and impossible because of resource War
because North Dakota is producing energy
because uh California is reliant on the
Colorado River it flows through Nevada
Nevada could shut it down Arizona could
shut it down Colorado could shut it down
and then everyone Downstream is pulling
out guns a lot of Chinese were shutting
down a river that was going into uh
India that was a big that's a great
retention spot between the two countries
National divorce supporter I I uh I I
also agree with you I don't think that
it would be completely peaceful but who
is going to be the unpeaceful one in
that situation but I mean who China and
international divorce but what do you
mean who like the federal government
will tell the states they can't leave
that but it's not about States it's not
about States leaving
the the idea that Civil War is is I said
it's 50 billion times is going to follow
the track of 1861 is an absurd Nation
like one time this thing happened and
now everyone's like that's how all Civil
Wars will always be no more likely what
will happen is uh Arizona will say we
need to build a a reservoir because of
the drought impacts we've been having so
we're going to begin construction Nevada
then says if you do this you will cut
off our water supply for 16 months and
we will die and they'll say if we don't
do this we will die and then Nevada says
you are not cutting our water off and
then Arizona says Try Us
there you go the question is whether or
not the federal government can be
stretched so thin people under people
overestimate the power of the U.S uh of
U.S federal law enforcement and of the
military if we are engaged in Conflict
uh on a border or internationally and we
and we actively are with U.S trips being
sent to Europe and confidence is lost in
the federal government for a variety of
reasons all that needs happen is not
that a state secedes but that estate has
a problem that cannot be adjudicated
properly and there is no federal law
enforcement to come and prevent violence
from erupting I don't know if that can
happen or when it could happen or
whatever I'm saying in the event
that a national divorce happens
it doesn't have to be that Nevada files
a declaration of secession it can be
that Nevada just says guys we're not
we're losing water and the Biden
Administration has not responded to us
they've told us they're strapped and
they can't send law enforcement we're on
our own now and then you get State you
get Interstate conflict I'm wondering
from your perspectives Ashley the thing
I have issue I have with libertarianism
I feel like it doesn't jive with the
presidency because it's such an
authoritarian role like you're the
military commander you suppose that's
your main job is command the military so
like how would you handle the military
in in with Taiwan or if there wasn't you
said you wouldn't issue a draft you just
let people like be on their own yeah I
think if you're gonna join the military
you should always be on voluntary terms
we should never make anybody a war
fighter uh because we say they have to
be a Warfighter I think that goes way
against the whole entire identity of of
consent
um and so yes I'm against I'm definitely
against that uh listen I I don't know I
I know that since the Nixon ERA with the
Taiwan and China thing we've kind of had
this double fail say for like China
don't mess with Taiwan we may go to war
with you and then with Taiwan it was
kind of like listen Taiwan don't mess
with China we may not protect you and
it's worked since then
um but now obviously it's not and I
think it's it's such a weird thing
because we have
you know we have the a government that's
saying Russia is not allowed to
um uh take a rogue Province from Ukraine
but on the other hand uh China's not
allowed to take I guess I'm mixing that
up they're they're not allowed to have
their Rogue province in in Taiwan right
and uh Ukraine is has to let there's uh
has to get theirs back or whatever you
know even though they're mostly ethnic
Russians living there and uh so I I just
I'm not gonna like go and play you know
Civil War around the country with our
military it's not worked out for us it's
not worked out in the Middle East
um that for decades and decades and
decades I think it's just it's it's it's
bad I mean just to defend against an
invasion yeah and that's and I'm not I'm
not at all against National Defense I
think we we have a much better chance of
Defending against an invasion if we have
our troops at home because no you know
nobody's trying to come here and attack
us since since 1930s right I mean Pearl
Harbor 40s uh and it's and that's still
technically very very far away yeah
Hawaii is very far yeah it was a
military operation yeah it's far away
it's like when we're talking about
Taiwan Taiwan is 7 000 miles away from
here it's only nine what 90 miles from
China you know what I mean if we go and
have this this theater and over there by
Taiwan we're gonna lose an aircraft
carrier maybe and what's going to happen
what's Joe Biden going to do if we lose
an aircraft carrier I mean it's gonna
get real ugly real quick it feels I
wanna so much like Ukraine like it's
just a it's another sense of land that's
right next to their country that we have
control of it's like dude what let's
jump to this story from NBC News
secretaries of State get ready for
possible challenges to Trump's ballot
access Arizona secretary of state is the
latest to say his office is grappling
with the potential effects of a move to
block Trump from the ballot okay you got
Arizona you got New Hampshire you've got
Florida and it's going to keep happening
my friends if in October of 2024 they
announce
at least one state Donald Trump's name
has been removed for he is an
insurrectionist and the 14th Amendment
do not be surprised they've indicted him
they've indicted his lawyers this is not
above them
I think at that point
things get bad
but Tucker Carlson was saying that
they're not going to let Trump win they
won't do covet they'll start war with
Russia which we're already in but
they'll formally declare do you think
they would be beyond that it is that it
is beyond them to do this these
Democrats what they're doing now in
Arizona is they're going oh gee golly
it's such a hard question I mean we want
to be fair but Donald Trump did an
Insurrection guess we got to remove his
name and they're talking about taking
his name off the primaries this way I
think all the Republicans to drop out
because Trump is the clear FrontRunner
and if Arizona or New Hampshire or
Florida takes his name off the primary
ballot and this results in say Vivek or
DeSantis winning
neither of them will win in the general
and it will cause a major rupture and
split giving the election to Joe Biden
maybe but Chuck Todd loves Vivek I
watched that interview do you guys see
those guys Chuck like really respects
that guy I think he's like Chuck is
terrified of trump and annoyed with
Trump and is like yo this guy's actually
smart and is has a plan and he's
interesting to listen to I uh I don't I
don't get the feeling that people that
would be considered mainstream are
giving Vivek any serious respect they're
claiming this weekend 911 was an inside
job last weekend he was on Chuck Todd it
was pretty cool uh China first he was a
little confrontational like combative
and then Chuck started to soften up and
you can tell he's got a lot of respect
for him I think so what do you what do
you think about uh Trump having his name
removed from the ballot I think there is
definitely not be above the Democrats to
try and do that and listen beneath yes
and and trust me as someone who's had to
go around the country and fight for
ballot access for our candidates for the
last six years I mean it sucks um but
yeah I don't think it's beneath the
Democrats what do people definitely do I
think they'll definitely try what do you
think happens if in the general October
they take Trump's name off of say
Georgia Wisconsin and Arizona
I mean Trump's Trump's not going to win
but how does this country react I mean I
think it's going to be violent yeah 100
I think it's gonna get violent you think
January 6 will look like a cakewalk I
believe what is a cakewalk it's it was a
game it was a game we used to play in
elementary school you would win cakes
yes absolutely yeah it was a game we
used to play in the uh in the I don't
remember how we played it with
blindfolds I don't remember I honestly
don't remember but I know that it was a
game where you won cakes people brought
cakes and then you played this game and
oh wow I don't even think
I think if just people just start doing
massive occupations of places like
that's gonna be the scary thing you're
just gonna see thousands of souls not
even necessarily violent or angry just
occupying places
I think it'll be really ugly it started
as uh get-togethers on uh slave
plantations uh where people would have
dance contests to win cake oh cool we
played it we played it in school when I
was a kid now you can't do it now
because the school
Chuck Todd seeming to enjoy Vivek is
because I think this is this is
understood they're going to remove Trump
from the ballot they're going to stop I
mean trumps and they're going to try
they've already decided he's not going
to be the president we have a deep State
get it through your head and they're
trying to soften Vivek on the people
right now so that they're not so upset
and they have someone to vote I don't
trust I don't trust but they don't they
just want them they just want them to
suck it up and vote for him I think he's
listen I think that uh first of all I've
called Vivek out on Twitter a million
times for a debate if you're watching
this I'd love to debate you anytime but
I know that you'll get kicked out of the
uh the primary debates if you do that I
understand is that a rule or something
or yeah apparently I did not know this
but I've been I've been challenging him
to debate for a while he said some
things in the in the debates that I take
issue with and I'd like to talk to him
at least just talk to him on my show
about it and uh and uh someone actually
posted the rnc's rules that says uh if
you uh if any candidate takes place uh
takes part in any of the unsanctioned
debates around the country they will be
immediately removed what if you guys are
just here having a conversation yeah
that would be different and I'd be okay
I don't think the vehicle do it because
I mentioned him talking with Dave Smith
and he was more like well oh yeah he was
like I'm only going to go for the real
candidates Trump yeah well you're not
gonna he's not even gonna get within 10
feet of trump doesn't want to and I said
that I said you know I'm likely to be on
the ballot as a vegetarian well yeah I
guess that would change things and and I
said that the the the Republican debate
the primary debate was just a VP
interview that's really what it was I
think the Vic's great yeah um I don't I
don't think he's perfect I don't I don't
think any politician is out there with
like their actual diary you know
broadcasting their thoughts a lot of
what they say is well crafted planning
you know you go to someone like Vivek
and he runs a biotech firm and you say
what's your position on Aleppo
he's going to be like to be completely
honest I haven't thought I don't I don't
know enough about it I haven't thought
enough about it and I'd be it'd be
difficult for me to give you an answer
Vivek is the kind of guy who would say
something like that on the spot but go
research it research it and then come
back and give you a general cursory
response so what that means to me is
when you ask him on these debate stages
like how do you feel about Medicare and
Medicaid he'll give you an answer but
it's like not it's not like his
specialty right so he's giving you the
political response but uh just from
meeting the guy we've had him on IRL
twice once with me once with Sheamus and
we've had him on the culture War
I mean it feels like you're talking to a
real person yeah it doesn't like we've
had politicians and I I cringe without
naming anybody you have the politicians
on the show that are playing the
politician game and it is so annoying
it's like dude don't come on this show
if you're not going to be definitive on
your positions and your answers no the
vague outright was like he's just like
chilling and I'm like what about service
guaranteeing citizenship and he's like
yeah and then we had we talked about the
idea that if you want to vote in this
country after you male or female sign up
for the Selective Service you get a
voter ID card right and that's it I I
really like that idea uh you don't think
it's perfect but I like the idea I I
like the idea as well I don't think that
uh I don't think that limiting voting is
a winning argument I don't think that
there's an appetite in the United States
for it so he's abolished the 19th
amendment I didn't say that
so yes there is a difference between
what I want and what I think there is an
appetite for in the United States
there's a significant difference because
ideals aren't necessarily your platform
so it's I got a plan for you guys it's
really really simple let me hear it is
called the Omnibus Bill and what you do
is you write a single sentence uh or you
write a sentence that says citizens of
the United States may only vote with a
voter ID received after registering for
The Selective Service irrespective of
biological sex and then you just slide
it right in the middle of those six
thousand pages and watch them sign it I
mean problem solved you you have a point
No One's Gonna read it I don't I don't I
don't support uh I don't think that
that's a good way to pass it either I
would love to see you know a return to
the idea that there are things that are
acceptable for the federal government to
legislate and there are things that are
not and it most Things fall under the
not category and that's essentially the
goal of limiting people's vote right or
the idea the idea is there are things
that people are voting on that they're
voting you know in ways that harm the
country and stuff so like I get it
better people are like oh we want to we
would like to limit the the damage
that's possible by the whims of people
voting because essentially that's what
you're talking about people people vote
on whims
um with emotions and I understand but I
don't think that that's something that
the right should really try to seriously
engage in because I think that it is a
total loser yeah I agree it's such a
shutdown of morale like 90 million
people will be like what the hell are
you talking about even the people the
same people the same people that'll say
oh this is a terrible idea and blah blah
those are the same people that will
never read a goddamn book to vote like
they would go and they will vote the
most idiot for the most idiotic reasons
they'll vote because they like the guy
smile or they like you know she's
whatever they'll vote for the absolute
most awful awful reasons but then
they'll sit there and be like no I need
to have my vote counted because you know
I gotta vote for the guy with the nicest
smile because I can't be bothered that
happens all the time which is the why
that's the whole reason to say you
should limit votes yeah I think after
the TV was invented like there's this
big shift in presidential candidates
became yep drastically more attractive
well that's the famous story that Nixon
on radios they said he won and on TV he
said he lost he's on TV he was sweaty
that interview was worth that debate is
awesome he was so sweaty and Kennedy
came in so cool and same thing with
Clinton and Clinton's first debate he
looked like a like a and then he
must have had somebody be like look this
is where he messed up this is where he
messed up this is where he messed up and
he he examined it in his second debate
dominate you know why George Bush you
know why Trump
crushes it in the debates because he's
he's not giving you that canned
political garbage sure because people
are so tired and sick of oh deep water
Horizon as an oil oil spill the
executive comes out goes we're sorry we
work really hard and with your help and
assistance we will clean oh shut up yeah
we know the moment you went back you're
sweating and you're like how much is my
bonus going down
and then Donald Trump goes on stage and
just interrupts and just says whatever
and it's like
well there you go I agree I agree 100 I
I definitely sympathize more with
somebody who feels like a normal person
than a canned response and you know
that's my campaign's a blue collar
working class campaign who's trying to
appeal to the middle class so I I get it
100 I like the fact that he's 6'3 and
215. yeah yeah yeah I think that's
that's exactly definitely true yeah very
true we gotta we gotta jump to this
story ladies and gentlemen it's a sad a
sad story a sad story from the Daily
Mail Mitch McConnell freezes again
Republican senator 81 Sparks health
concerns by suddenly stopping for 30
seconds I'm gonna play for you uh this
video and it's very strange
and let's make sure we have the uh the
audience check this out
I'm sorry I had a hard time hearing you
that's okay what are your thoughts on
running for re-election in 2020 . what
are my thoughts about what running for
re-election in 2018.
oh sure
he's gone did you hear the question
Senator running for re-election in 2026
no he's not good he is yes he went yes
the response that was a quick question
I'm sorry we're gonna need a minute
they keep playing it this just gets
crazier
he's not incapacitated I think they're
trying to move him yeah he's look at his
hands on the podium he's holding on he's
gripping because he's gonna fall over
look how hard he's holding onto the
podium he's trying not to collapse
somebody else have a question please
speak up
this guy's stroking out
it wasn't a stroke look at him holding
on yeah he's about to fall and she's
holding his back
you can't get his arm off the podium
yeah
terrible
[Music]
whoa the moving his head around and he's
looking it's not a stroke that's not
what a stroke looks like he's he's I
think his blood pressure may be dropping
he may be about to pass out where's
anybody trying to help him I'd be so
concerned if I was standing there
[Music]
um
Cameron uh do you have a comment on
Daniel Cameron
very close
[Music]
dude he's Friday he's out he's out of
there
why would they leave him there
they don't want to show the camera that
he's sick the craziest point is this
when she's looking at the question
Senator running for re-election in 2026
okay yes but it doesn't answer it I know
just yes like whoa and then his hands
holding on for dear life he was holding
himself up he looks like he has
full-blown dementia to me and and I yeah
I worked in skilled nursing homes for a
decade and that's what it looks like
it's the same thing Joe Biden does he
does the same crap he's sundowning it's
he's like oh and probably the the uh uh
bursts of Rage yes that Joe Biden does
and the ice cream right the ice cream
man we used to give patients ice cream
when when they started having their
sundowning moment towards the evening
give them ice cream and they'd forget
all about it and so I see the guy with
the ice cream and I'm like he's
sundowning man yeah he's got dementia
he's sundowning there's no so there was
that famous video where Joe Biden snaps
at the reporter or whatever who asks
about I forgot the issue he's like jobs
yelling yeah and it's uh what I was told
is people who are suffering from
dementia no they can't know like they're
cognizant of the failing a question was
asked of me and I can't put it together
and it's frustrating being unable and so
they get really angry and just go oh and
they have these outbursts
sometimes violently right they get
really angry this is the weakest I've
ever seen a politician in the United
States have you seen Feinstein yeah
they're all they're all she's like in a
wheelchair like that I'm barely alive
yeah yeah she's like they're carting
around she gave power of attorney to her
daughter and she's just being wheeled
around and they're they're like now that
you're back are gonna watch like I never
left it's like ma'am you've been gone
for a long time I will say that uh I've
seen a lot more politicians looking
bad yeah over the last couple years than
I've ever seen the old days my entire
life uh or you know maybe they're
adrenal Chrome Supply right now I wonder
if coven messed people up the Old Guard
doesn't want to let go of power the old
guy I don't know if this is like this
like I'm younger here I don't know if
like in the 80s and 70s we saw something
similar of these older politicians that
wouldn't let go I never saw that I
didn't get public speeches like this
yeah what would the founding fathers
have us do uh I don't know you know I
think the issue is Mitch McConnell is
just uh he he's he's waiting for the
Genesis device to be repaired in the
basement the Capitol Building to
rejuvenate him back to a youthful 20. I
think it'll then masquerade as an intern
what a loser to think that this is what
the most important thing in his life
what do you what do you mean by what are
the what would they do if they had a guy
with dementia in Congress like go home
man go home would they grab him and pull
them out of there and be like you're not
allowed back in I don't imagine no
that's not true there's a bunch of
politicians who are whacked out there
was like a Supreme Court Justice who was
out of his mind there's nothing like if
you want to know all you got to do is
look in the Constitution like there are
methods to take people to remove people
from Office impeachment stuff like all
like there's a lot of times where like
people are like oh well what would they
do it's like all of the questions can be
answered by reading the Constitution so
someone gets dementia you impeach them
well you you could just write the
answers in there if the president was 25
25th amendment or something like that
but there's there's recalls there's
there's way to do I don't know if it's
it might not technically be an
impeachment because I think that's
actually the trial to remove them up
from office so there might there's the
indictment yeah okay so so it probably
wouldn't be called an impeachment but
it'd be some there are definitely
methods to get people that are in that
are incapacitated or cannot fulfill the
office there are methods that the
founders had to take them out of office
it's just that there needs to be an
appetite for it among the population and
among the people that are actually in
power that means people have to get in
touch with their Congress people and
their senators and be like hey or
whatever if it's just Congress it might
be maybe it's just a congress person or
whatever but you didn't get in touch
with them be like hey this is a problem
for me I'm a constituent and this is a
problem for me so until people actually
act nothing will happen I will say that
correlation is not causation but I have
seen a lot more uh politicians like this
since the demise of Jeffrey Epstein for
sure so
could be an Adrena Chrome thanks
now that Epson shuts down Mitch is like
all over all of them I mean we're
watching politicians do stuff like this
on a daily basis I'm like you know they
know it's not now hold on there a minute
you realize Media Matters are going to
take what you just said seriously that's
okay and then it's going to be in the
independent and the daily I want to be
very clear about my presidential
campaign this is we're running a very
serious campaign but I'm I'm the first
libertarian that's going to tell you as
a as a candidate for a Libertarian
president that I am not going to win the
presidency okay I'm not under any
illusion they're going to let us in the
white house we want five percent to
change the political landscape what is
America what does it do gives us
National major party status it will
include us in the debates in the next
election it makes us have it makes the
federal government have to do all the
same things for the Republicans and
democrats for the Libertarians as well
and then you run like a superstar yeah
and then we run a superstar they get in
the debates you know we then we start we
start being a party that someone can
trust so I'm not going to come out here
and lie to everybody and be like whoa
any any libertarian candidate that's
telling you he's going to win the
presidency this year is a liar or
suffering from delusions of grandeur I
mean we're we're my goal is five percent
change the political landscape for the
rest of
Eternity in the United States make
another a national political party then
you have a a candidate that's actually
circling the waters making these people
have to start
um uh uh governing like they campaign
everything's different after that
everything what's the difference between
running a third party and running
independent
uh third so third so we fought for
ballot access as Libertarians already
we're gonna get on the ballot um and our
party will have we'll be on about at
least 40 some states um we may not get
all 50 this year because we don't have
the money but the fact that there's
already it's just a lot of money is a
cost uh so it just depends there's some
states that are really bad like uh
Tennessee needs like 200 000 signatures
to get on the ballot we've been fighting
Tennessee but ballot access laws for
ever since I've been in the party since
like 2010.
um New York is very hard uh Alabama has
been very hard uh some states we have it
already and it's easy and some states we
get it by running a smaller down ballot
candidates that get a certain percentage
and we've gotten it that way so you need
signatures not necessarily money
signatures and or money yeah or money or
one or the other some some states are
like that some states are just
signatures what about taking over a
state uh New Hampshire is has been
working on that for a long time and I
think it's I think it's a I I love the
free state project I think those guys
have done a lot of really great stuff
there I don't know I'm sure Phil would
agree in some ways right I think they're
doing great things yeah I endorse the I
endorse the free state project for sure
I think that's a very smart idea I
talked about doing it in Iowa too I
think that Iowa's a very very very uh
conservative Liberty loving State too
West Virginia is but it's got to be
cleaned up yes there's a lot of red tape
we didn't send a single Democrat to
Washington from from Iowa not one wow
not a single one you're welcome America
yeah I feel like uh West Virginia is
ready to have a big evolution yes yeah
it was it was it was a Democrat state
for a long time uh what was it Riley
Moore we've had him on the show several
times he's the first Republican
Treasurer he's been Democrat yeah he's
fantastic any skates skateboards nice
stairs yeah super cool it would be cool
to have some sort of power in the in the
state government
I don't care about political power uh
you know it is it is interesting running
a show like this and and knowing as many
people as I do
because it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's an interesting
perspective that I did not have when I
was younger when it comes to the idea of
like lobbying and how this stuff works
like quite literally there are there are
people who are in office that will come
on this show and have a conversation
with me and those exchange of ideas can
influence laws and other parts it's like
it's really it's really that simple
often you know just literally talking to
a politician then they can draft
something and they can change things
West Virginia has I think like 1.5 or so
million people maybe it's 1.6 maybe it's
1.3 I'm not sure so it actually is
substantially easier in a state like
West Virginia or even New Hampshire
where the population is
smaller than West Virginia I believe
right or right around the same but I
during covet I went down to the state
house there and lobbied with these guys
I got interviews I did interviews with
Paul like state legislators we have uh
great state legislature that's why I
want to do uh the Martinsburg project
yes it's like I'm not going to go for a
state I'm just gonna go for like a very
small City County and uh uh well it's
Berkeley County okay yeah and then
Martinsburg is the uh is the town but
we've got properties in West Virginia in
Jefferson and Berkeley County so this is
the Eastern Panhandle you've got
basically what's happening is uh what I
would describe as a woke incursion this
is Maga country unquestionably right now
where we do the studio we're actually in
Maryland and because we operate out of
the Tri-State which is Maryland Virginia
West Virginia but we're setting up all
the new studio stuff all the new stores
everything is going to be in West
Virginia it is in West Virginia and what
we're finding is that the locals who are
in these towns are getting increasingly
frustrated with the people from DC who
are coming out here and masquerading as
Maga but secretly trying to implement
woke and communist policies and Marxism
and stuff like that we saw it in local
schools the people would run for school
board and be like we want you know
church and Faith and family and then as
soon as they get in they'd be like all
right bring in all the weird you know
porn and everything for the kids
Heretics for sure yeah I mean you call
them a heretic but like it's just
they're subversives they're masquerading
as right you know we we're locals here
and we want to do good and then the way
they do they have drag shows with with
children in West Virginia so my my
thought is like as long as we're here
and we're investing I encourage
everybody to come out to uh Martinsburg
Berkeley County and what we'll do is
effectively the free city project where
we just will help Revitalize a small
town yeah there's there's Legacy
families who have businesses there
they're great grandparents founded and
passed down to them who have been
complaining about how this wokeness
keeps creeping in they're seeing signs
everywhere these events are popping up
and they feel like they're losing I've
had City councilmen say they're they're
passing these Pride resolutions against
the wishes of the Town thousands of
people come out in protest but it
doesn't matter because they still sneak
in and start passing these things and
I'm like then we need to tell them no
yeah that's the Communist Playbook man I
mean right they've been they've been
telling us they were going to do these
things for years and years and years
decades Generations almost like having a
centralized place where people go and
sign some papers to affect everyone else
is defunct
right
it's it's just
we have so much respect uh the the
um the constitutional republic
Republicans and I don't mean Republican
political party I mean those who believe
in the constitutional republic all
Americans are Republicans they are not
we all are of the Republic there are
four Republican yes we are that is
incorrect because right now in places
like Charlestown and in Martinsburg in
in smaller Port other other areas in
West Virginia you have Multicultural
Democrats people who believe that the
system should not be run by a
constitution but by the the 50 50.1
percent majority and so and and also
it's not even about democracy and a
great deal it's about we are the better
people who can who should rule over you
yes so they lie to get power and then
they vote for things against the wishes
of the public to the consternation and
protest and they don't care and the only
way you change it is if you get
organized and we have say like a free
city project and we kind of I feel like
say push back I interrupted you you were
talking about centralized government in
the Republic public and uh because I
think it's a bad I think sending people
to a building somewhere to go sign
paperwork to affect everybody else well
I cut you off and said that we're all
Republican because we live in a
republican to carry on what I'm talking
about you have marxists people who
believe in the concept of what they call
Multicultural democracy and you have
people who believe in constitutional
republicanism the people who are in West
Virginia for the most part see their
City members of the city council I
shouldn't say all of West Virginia can
we talk about where I'm at and they
passed in Charlestown a pride resolution
recognizing pride month
everyone's pissed off they had a massive
uh uh a protest all of these people
protesting marching but how did they
protest they silently pray as they March
the city but the people on the council
don't care all they care about is
getting that political power so you have
all of these people who are really angry
about what's going on and they live
there but they respect the idea of the
constitutional republic so they don't do
anything out of line they simply say
well we better vote next time what are
the marxists and the Multicultural uh
democracists whatever they call them
doing saying just keep lying to them
because we're smarter than they are and
then we can make change and the cops
will do as we said tactics for sure and
it's hands down they've been doing this
for a long long time here it's
subversion they get in they said we're
going to get into your institutions
we're going to get into your kids day
cares we're going to get into your
health care we're going to get into your
government and we're going to take it
over that's what they've been telling us
they're gonna do that people love to the
the people especially like Centrist
people they they like to say that the
right has been uh Chicken Little about
socialist and and leftists and stuff
like that but the evidence is that there
are marxists all throughout our society
in places uh like in places of Education
you know knowledge Creation in schools
uh and in the federal government there's
a straight up Marxist that just one want
to see in Colorado and he's calling for
an actual cultural revolution these are
real serious problems in America that
have dramatic consequences worldwide
because the United States is the last
place where there is a significant voice
to have a control to have government
controlled and small now it's not the
majority Voice still currently both
Republicans and Democrats want to have a
bigger government than I'm comfortable
with but of all the places on Earth the
most people that are looking for a
limited government happen to be in the
United States the FBI well not
originally but in the 50s McCarthyism
went hard against communism
so you think so so would you advocate
for us using government a secret police
force to no so now it's not a good thing
but then it was I think it was right but
the tactics were bad yeah the tactics
weren't great uh I've I think that
listen I I you know in my head I take a
very Hapa approach to this I think that
you know if you want to have a
Libertarian Society you can have no
tolerant tolerance at all in your
libertarian Society for communism I
believe what does that mean Hapa yeah
Hans Hermann Hapa is a oh yeah he's a
he's a writer who talks a lot about
Liberty just like no communist celeb
yeah I mean you can't you know he takes
a little further than that but yeah he
says that you know in a uh libertarian
Society you cannot you cannot suffer the
Communists they have to be physically
removed like not even a Communist party
not at all because in Canada they have a
Communist Party
my view has been uh I would say maybe
like six years ago my view was I believe
in free speech even if you're a
communist or a fascist or whatever where
we must defend Free Speech now my
position is if you believe in free
speech then I will defend your free
speech if you don't believe people
should have free speech then I will
defend your request to not have free
speech and not help you when you get
silent that's self-defense my friend I
mean absolutely I mean I'm just giving
them what they want yeah you know so you
know at libertarian guy being like I
should be allowed to speak go back
you're right you should and someone says
no he shouldn't then you shouldn't die
because I believe everyone should get
what they vote for
you know what I mean so like San
Francisco yeah Republicans this video
out of San Francisco where like the lady
I'm born and raised there I think it was
SF lady goat Parks her car and walks
inside when she comes out all of her
windows are broken and someone took a
dump in the car and oh my God everything
five minutes you know who yeah you know
who turned San Francisco into that right
who was it Gavin Newsom he was the mayor
of San Francisco that when I was a kid I
grew up in Oakland right across the
bridge one of the greatest big cities in
the country so much fun to hang out he's
pretty safe it was not what it is today
Gavin Newsom is the one who made it
actually really legitimately a shitty
City because they have poo Maps right
that you can see all the poops in a poo
Department he's the one that did that
and instead of you know the the state
going hey this guy is horrible
absolutely terrible we gotta get rid of
him they made him the governor you know
you know what I love about San Francisco
when I was there it's uh it's five bucks
to come in to San Francisco and it's
free to leave yes yeah well and and but
you know why they do that it's because
they want you to leave and they want to
make sure people who are poor and low
income have a harder time getting in
it's it's just it's a pressure system a
lot of good skating there though was
that a lot of good skating there though
yeah yeah yeah yeah a lot of good Hills
yeah so how would you deal with the
Communist uh Revolution that we're
sensing like if not McCarthyism in the
blacklisting of people that are involved
yeah well what do you do do you round
them up I I don't think I don't think we
can do that as Americans I think that I
think that we we need to fight culture
wars I'm sure that we can't do that as a
marriage yes yeah sorry I guess I should
have said that yeah I don't think we I
we definitely can do that as Americans
but I do believe that we can win the
culture War by United in the culture but
you saw that uh Josie redheaded
libertarian had that post a long time
ago talking about the 1964 Civil Rights
Act explicitly states that Communists
are not human yeah not not in that sense
it says they're they're they're exempt
yeah that these Provisions do not apply
to people who are communists members of
communist political organizations
meaning that you are allowed to
discriminate against someone for being a
communist it's so crazy because we're
all in this together this communist men
no I'm saying that's the Communist
Mantra wait a minute it's so easy to
compassionately fall into believing it
or feeling right it's all of us man
we're on this and then as soon as you
get power it's you right that's the part
of what the left does intentionally and
people hear it all the time but it's
almost as if the word is lost meaning
the left specifically the far left is
intentionally subversive so you look at
the Nazis right you look at the the
white nationalists people like Nick
Fuentes and stuff Nick Fuentes is dying
for people to hear him say exactly what
he believes he will tell you that he's
racist he will tell you that he believes
that there should be a policy that gets
rid of you know people that he considers
undesirable he will tell you right out
the left is gonna lie they're gonna tell
you that no this is for democracy we all
get a a say and Etc et cetera Etc they
will lie and tell you all kind of good
things and then once they're in a
position of power the boot comes down so
as much as the national socialists and
the Nazis are terrible the commies are
worse because at least you can identify
the Nazis you can see them put them and
be like okay these are the people we
can't listen to and it's clear because
they'll tell you what they believe the
commies will lie to you so it's like
well I don't know is this guy just a
Democrat because they're going to tell
you oh well I'm you know I'm a liberal
I'm a progressive no you're a Kami
you're an authoritarian that will kill
people
the Communists will lie their way into
being a teacher kids absolutely show
them their show them your I got an idea
absolutely I have an idea I know what we
could do we can create a communist
Utopia not not hold on not everywhere
but we just find like maybe a thousand
acres maybe in Wyoming or something or
Montana some federal controlled land we
you know put a big fence around it we
call it communist Utopia everyone's
equal everyone gets access and we say
you are free to go there if you want and
we will operate this this jurisdiction
exactly as you would like it to be so
diversity Equity inclusion committee
hearings and there will be a base level
of funding provided for the initial
startup and then all the Communists will
choose to go to that commune where they
will live as agrarian people and uh
they'll be killing each other in two
years it'll be it'll be bad right yeah
absolutely killing each other and eating
people probably
there's no doubt no doubt in my mind I
mean the the Soviets literally had to
make posters in Ukraine during the orbit
I think it was in in like the 30s or
something during the holiday morning
don't eat your kids don't eat your kids
yeah like come on
that's crazy I just like I want to go
back to the term constitutional
Republican I really liked that term I
I've uh I'm doing a uh I'm recording and
editing an audiobook for the great David
Benner uh who wrote uh uh Thomas Payne
the life of radicalism books out on
Amazon but I'll have the audiobook out
soon and I I never really you never
really hear that term constitutional
Republican or republicanism in in 2023
but it's all throughout that book it's
so important because the the subversive
thing about naming these political
parties the Republican party or the
Democrat doesn't mean that they're they
value the Republic at all you can call
your party whatever you want it doesn't
mean that you are that just like these
stupid bills a safe puppies act when
they're so but it does now interesting
sometimes like you you find the people
that are geared towards the Constitution
to tend towards the Republican party but
and that the Democrats are more about
mob Rule and MOB control but that
doesn't mean that they value democracy
if they're trying to shut people's
voices down they're not Democrats but
but democracy is the oppression of the
majority but you still let the others
talk you still have to
in order for democracy to Reign you
would otherwise it's tainted we could
talk so democracy has given us what we
have today
we've not had democracy right well not
entirely not mob democracy
I mean democracy 51 can take the food
away from the only 49. we right we've
always been a constitutional republic
with elected representatives sure so
we've like some states have the
proposition system which is you know
Democratic to a great degree but what
got us here is liberalism
liberalism is a great thing but too many
people just said you know I'm gonna mind
my own business and not fight right I
think what I I I I don't blame
liberalism I think it the class the
truest sense of liberalism the founding
fathers and their views Classical
liberalism should be defended I just
think the issue is weak men make hard
times and our the generations before us
allowed Communists to come in and do
these things and corporations because
they kept because this is the point it's
like what I was saying about what's
going on in West Virginia the people who
live in these places believe in the
constitutional republic so they follow
the rules the marxists Do Not and don't
follow the rules it's like playing a
game of Monopoly where you're watching
the opponent just take money from the
bank and you're like you can't do it and
they go I can and you go okay I guess
right well I would never do that it's
like well no no crap you're losing
they're cheating
that's what people tell me when I say I
want to ban the the get rid of the NFA
and ban the uh in in ICS right and
people are like well then criminals are
going to be able to do this and do that
and do that and I'm like they're already
doing that and go to Chicago man they
got they got 50 round magazines on their
Glocks with a illegal switch Yeah
Fallout all it does all it does is keep
me from not being able to switch oh
jealous
I want machines on kids running around
with full auto Glocks with extended mags
50 round 50 round magazines and I can't
have one and we can't have one because
because of because it's illegal and come
on those laws don't do anything but make
sure that those criminals thugs have
those guns and I don't we're gonna go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it it is uh we've done no marketing for
the show so everything that we have and
and where we're at is all thanks to you
guys who watch the show telling your
friends about it and I I really do
appreciate it because uh you know I I
look at some of these shows and I wonder
how they get so big and recently I've
noticed something really interesting I
don't know if you guys have noticed this
people are running their podcast as
advertisements on YouTube now full
two-hour long shows oh awesome but it's
insane I'm like I'm trying to listen to
music and then all of a sudden I hear a
guy talking about what's going on I look
it's like ad will be done in one hour
and 30 minutes I'm like it's annoying
what yeah man I do not like that it's
because yeah when you're trying to clean
the house and you put music on you know
it's gonna auto play well you know and
then wait a second I've been listening
to a guy talk for 10 minutes two hours
but you know what if one in a hundred
people say oh this is pretty good I like
it subscribe the ad works and they cost
a penny yep so anyway my point is we
don't do that we've never done that and
it's just uh the show exists because you
guys like it and I really do appreciate
it so uh word of mouth if you want to
support us and download the timcast app
on the Google Play Store for Android now
available and uh if you're having any
issues because there's so many different
Android devices things may happen just
uh send send an email to members
timcast.com or there might be an email
for the app but uh we uh we're we're
excited where we're at uh become a
member at timcast.com go to timcast.com
click join us we're gonna have an
uncensored show coming up at about 10 pm
you don't want to miss it they're uh not
so family friendly we swear a lot
they're good fun and then you guys as
members get to call in and ask us
questions let's read
I'm not your buddy guys as it's fairly
unnerving knowing the Fate The Fate
humanity and whether Liberty will mean
anything going forward will be
determined fairly soon here
being determined as we speak it is
that's just right that's right history
has been is happening all around you my
friends
it is unnerving but are you ready to
fight I mean that's really what the
question comes down to are you ready to
push back are you ready to keep are you
ready to continue voting the way you've
been voting for the last I got 50 years
I mean look you know let's go back five
years let's go back to 2018 let's go
back 2019. and I'm sitting in my little
desk saying like food prices are going
up there's going to be food shortages
there's conflict happening you guys need
to speak up I wonder now how many people
who heard me say that and said ah I
don't know I don't want to risk it are
now looking at their grocery bill being
like I wish I said something five years
I'm one of those people that spoke up
because of you I wouldn't be do I
wouldn't be here with the show if you
didn't want to get it started there you
go
but I just think
if more people in say 2019 or 2020
did come out and say I will not stand
for these things then Donald Trump would
have stayed president and we would be in
a very very different spot no no no
money going to Ukraine for this crazy
War we'd have better security on the
southern border Donald Trump was
bringing manufacturing back he was far
from a perfect candidate but we got more
peace in the Middle East no new Wars a
lot of really good things I would I
would be willing to bet a large sum of
money it's never you can't prove it but
I'd be willing to bet that if Donald
Trump was President right now you would
not be crying over your your groceries
you would not be seeing these Tick Tock
videos of people being like I can't
afford this anymore I was crying over
toilet paper when uh Donald Trump was
still in office covid's a different
story and you can blame Trump for a lot
of what happened with code for sure but
I just mean like if people just
were more active and spoke up more and
and pushed back socially huge
Groundswell of change it happened so
fast it happens horizontally as well as
vertically 42 000 votes was all Trump
needed in three states that's it yeah
yeah it's gonna it's gonna take a big
push for sure but I think Trump's on
track to win if you look at the polling
right now he's rivaling Biden Biden's up
by .8 in the RCP average McLaughlin has
Trump up by one or two points and in
swing States up by like six or seven
yeah
A lot's going to change from now until
then but that's why they're going after
him to get his name off the ballot
because they know they will lose
all right
Jason Dixon says hey Tim can you please
promote the Discord after our show we
will continue the show long after you're
asleep only in Discord all are welcome
that's right ladies and gentlemen when
you become a member by going to
timcast.com and clicking join us you get
access to the Discord server where you
can hang out with like-minded
individuals who are doing a whole bunch
of crazy awesome stuff one of the things
they do is they have the after after
show where members hang out and host
their own show after we're long done
it's one of the coolest things ever
that's neat super excited yeah there's a
lot of the the Discord community that we
have they're doing a lot of really cool
things meeting meeting each other
becoming Friends building culture
building Community it's one of the
coolest things about being a member at
timcast.com true like Grassroots
organization right there uh through the
power of the internet you know it's
really cool to see
all right waffle Sensei says just wanted
to make a point about Vivek getting
booed at the debate he gets a booed when
he says I'm the only candidate not
bought and paid for when he says climate
change is a hoax they cheer check the
tapes okay all right they booed Trump
too when he would talk about when he was
talking about all the donors in the
audience and he was like these are the
donors that are booing me that I'm
talking about
all right
Europa Chronicle says Tim on August 16th
the FBI killed a second disabled veteran
Theodore destler in a pre-dawn raid in
the two weeks since the FBI has commit
been completely silent they haven't
given the reason for the raid please
help
shine a light on the issue
interesting
let's see here give me one second
there we go
all right where are we at
uh oh
okay there we go YouTube likes to do
this thing more tonight it refreshes
yep
all right neglectful sausage says reboot
robot Mitch Maga make animatronics great
again
hmm
God's other Sons says I want to see
Vivek run as VP mostly because I want to
see a debate between him and Kamala
yikes that would be fun to watch that
would be crazy should get squashed real
bad
he's very articulate for sure even if I
if you're even if I'm very rare weary of
the things he's saying I I think I
really want to see him debate Trump
because I think competition's only good
he's so good on that stage and it'll
Force Trump to be better
you know a lot of people I just got to
shut them down
I think he can roll with the punches
unlike most other people on the stage
though he's not gonna be like Chris
Christie no that's for sure plus like
Trump trump didn't know he couldn't shut
down the FBI because his deep State
advisors told him no you can't fire
people individually Trump and he's gay
he didn't read the law he just gave up
Vivek will annihilate him on that that
he doesn't read yeah that's true that's
true what I gotta read for not a
Statesman I'm not here to read loyal
Snoop Doge says this country could use a
Revival of McCarthyism
I mean at least the attitude yeah we
definitely we definitely need that
culture and attitude back for sure it's
time the the time to be uh weary and and
alert about communism has come and
passed it's time to start pushing back
on yeah it's there's there's a
significant problem in the United States
and it's not getting any better by
saying you know the problem you know the
Pirates of the Caribbean where he's like
you believe in yeah even scary movies do
you believe in cultural revolutions yet
because you're living through one you're
living Philip says tario and his lawyer
blamed Trump for January 6 in court some
of us think his sentencing got delayed
so he can testify against Trump I doubt
he'll get pardoned interesting that
would be an interesting yeah I won't be
surprised I mean Enrique Taria wasn't
even there that's the crazy thing he got
arrested before or something like that
yeah I don't know it was the date I I
guarantee you that Trump's not going to
Pardon him pardon him at that point I
think it was it was the day before he
was arrested
I can't remember but yeah he wasn't
there's a question
that he's uh some kind of informant
already so he was before yeah I got to
clarify my earlier statement Donald
Trump does read I just don't think he's
ever read the Constitution or laws or
anything like this
people in the comments like he reads so
like every other politics
Americans do you think have actually
read the comments exactly he may be able
to read but when people not read he
watches TV when people talk about the
Constitution they are only ever
referring to the Bill of Rights
most people yeah I would like 99 yeah
the black because of the Constitution we
have blah blah blah it's like okay are
you talking about like the distribution
of powers are you talking about like
article two are you talking about
Article Five what are you talking about
in the Constitution oh you're talking
about amendment number one yeah
that's it that's all I like the third
the third the third's great there's an
argument
um
we were talking about this the third
amendment doesn't just mean that
soldiers can't be quartered in your home
right it means you are free from
government influence in your own home
yes supposed to be yeah right yeah so
the internet appeared right well first
telephones appeared and what the issue
is the government can't do anything in
your house it's not about a soldier
being there it's also interpreted as or
it should be interpreted as the
government can't say something like we
need to put this listening device in
your house because we're in the middle
of an investigation might keep the
listing advice in their house and then
they use it on you when you're in your
house and they read your keystrokes and
crap my my favorite are the people who
are like oh we have to interpret the
this amendment this way or this this uh
the Bill of Rights this way because uh
you know the founders didn't give us any
guidelines on them like you know the
Federalist Papers I mean they literally
explain why they were doing these things
in separate documents so there is
explanations of these things if you just
go and look them up you know um and
there's a lot of books about those other
papers that that help you learn how to
read them so I like this chat from
mistress DAP in the regular old chat
saying Maga Swami
we were saying that Trump would call him
Rama Swampy
yeah he would for sure yeah he'd find
he'd find something interesting but but
vivek's playing the campaign very very
well and now what Trump said something
like he would consider him for VP
I forget who I was listening to today
but I was listening to someone talking
to Trump and he was talking about how uh
you know Vivek was the only guy that
that he would kind of like would be nice
to but also if it's the only guy that
hasn't attacked him he's also the only
guy that raised his hand to Pardon Trump
until until the Santa slipped around and
realized
to be fair Nikki Haley quickly does
raise her hand halfway The Vape goes
right up and as high as possible Nikki
Haley then raises her hand and then it
Cascades to the right and then Ron looks
looks and then you know Ron explained
himself in another video which probably
didn't get nearly as many views where he
said we already decided beforehand we
were going to do the stupid hand raise
thing and then when they asked the
question and they did it I'm like oh my
God you guys are really doing this all
right that was very smart then because
that somewhat someone agreed to not do
it and then did it that was very smart
in the debate that's a snake yeah
they're like come on guys that it was
the it was it was what Brett Bear and
Martha McCallum I don't know who agreed
with Ron ahead of time that they weren't
going to do the hand raised thing
it's like that thing where it's from The
Simpsons Bart convinces he tells all the
other kids let's prank the teacher and
turn all our desks around and they're
like yeah and when the teacher walks in
he's the only one who did it and then
they're like Bart detention is like ah
yes exactly it was a good setup man good
setup and execution for sure there's no
doubt about it if that's really what it
was that was good that was good all
right Jonathan Harris says incorrect
about China Taiwan is where the former
rulers fled to when the Rogues led by
Chairman Mao took over Taiwan also has
the latest chip Fabs that give the US an
edge in Ai and Tech in general that is
the Republic of China the actual real
government of China That's reoccupying
forces the CCP which has control of the
Mainland at present yeah well here's the
thing too AMD AMD can make those same
chips in Austin Texas I I used to work
for a company that built the robots that
made these these semiconductors right
like we'd ship them over to China the
robots that make these things and then
China would make them and send them back
to the United States it's like it's it's
a it's ridiculous it's all just this
whole thing is just a tripwire for war
in my opinion and and honestly we we
should be making those things at home we
have Cobalt mines here we have silica
mines here we have all the same stuff
it's not like we can't make those here
we have concerned unions here concern
about pollution the manufacturing I
guess sure prices well they get they get
a lot cheaper labor there I'm sure labor
wages and stuff but it's like it's like
we're close to it Taiwan Taiwan I don't
think Taiwan has like slave labor like I
I know that you get like that kind of
stuff in in China that's what I meant
like in in Taiwan if I understand
correctly because it's a you know it's a
western style democracy I think that
there is like protections for workers
and stuff they're Rogue province pardon
me they're a rogue Province yeah but
they they style their their government
it treats their population the way the
Western democracies do so I don't think
that there's a situation with slave
labor I imagine you know I mean I could
be wrong but I don't think that they
have the kind of deal where there's you
know sweatshops full of people working
for a dollar a day I don't think that
their economy is that poor I could be
wrong but I don't think so
the Sig piece is I have zero sympathy
for these old politicians gripping onto
their seat for dear life they should
resign their seat and enjoy what time
they have left all they are doing all
they are doing Place holding for
backdoor bureaucrats yeah
yeah yep Mitch McConnell time to resign
what do they do the governor appoints
someone
I think the governor would appoint
a special election yeah it would be I
think that it would be a special
election I mean in Illinois went to
prison because he was he would he would
assign the senate seat yeah I believe
that it would be a special there'd be a
special election and I'm sure there'd be
you know three candidates trying to Vie
for that is that because it's Kentucky
no I think that's well yeah probably in
Illinois when Barack Obama got elected
president Blagojevich was like I get to
pick who the senator is yes and he was
like and he's like you gotta pay or
whatever that's Illinois
too right I think the the different
states have different roles
well yeah they have to election rules
that's the thing about Pennsylvania that
if fetterman gets removed for medical
issues the governor will just appoint
the replacement it's bizarre it
definitely doesn't work that way in Iowa
for sure wow is that your home state uh
I'm originally from California but I've
lived in Iowa since 2020. I left my
flight left San Francisco airport at 11
55 and at midnight they instituted a
24-hour
my girlfriend lived there at the time
and so in Iowa and so I was like I'm
just going to come there for two weeks
to flatten the curve yeah and I came
with a backpack and a suitcase and now
we got seven kids and wow a whole huge
life there seven kids in two in three
years she had two I had I had a daughter
who didn't live with us today with we've
made two and I adopted my um my my
oldest daughter when I got custody of
her in 2020 I adopted her two younger
siblings that were gonna go to foster
care so I was able to get them so we
went from having just her two girls in
the house with the son on the way to
having seven kids in the house and we do
have one coming and uh where would you
place yourself in the abortion debate I
am I am pro-life I am very very very
pro-life and I do believe that you know
Murder is not good and uh that there
should be some kind of uh punishment for
doctors who commit murder I heard
Democrats told me you don't exist that
people that are pro-life don't adopt
kids yeah don't knock into the fuss no I
know more pro-life white Christian
people that have adopted than anybody
else uh and that's the truth and I'm not
saying that as a racial thing but you
know whenever I hear these pro-life
white you know nuclear family Christians
won't adopt I know so many that have
adopted so many people have adopted but
yeah we took in my my oldest daughter's
two younger siblings you can't really
trust what the left says about the right
because the left really doesn't know
anybody on the right because they've
already communicated them for their
lives they're just like Oh no you're you
you voted Donald Trump get out here I
can't talk to you yeah let's read uh we
got this from Robert Bradbury New
Hampshire is amazing free state project
and freedom also New Hampshire is one of
the first states trying to remove Trump
I'm not proud of my state yeah what's up
with that uh uh the the governor is a
Republican and he believes that Donald
Trump being on the uh ballot is bad
because Donald Trump can't win that's
what he believes I'm not saying that
that's what I do when these people these
never trumpers were like Trump can't win
they're lying listen
there's a lot of Republicans that are
never trumpers too that's what I'm
saying there's a bunch of them the the
DeSantis surrogates and the DeSantis
supporters saying Trump can't win It's
gotta be to sandus it's like Trump lost
by 40 000 votes no what do you mean he
can't win Biden his approval ratings in
the gutter the economy is bad he's being
held together by puppet strings right of
course Donald Trump can win like he only
needs to win a few States look what
they're doing desperate to stop him I'm
just sick of the lies that Trump can't
win I'm not saying he's going to win
tremendously you've got these polls
where it's like Trump has 20 of the
black vote and I'm like I don't know
about that those polls are interesting
but I doubt that's a big if but it's
like Trump barely won in 2016. he barely
lost in 2020. it's it's it's a close
race sure and and you've even got CNN
saying that has shown that Trump is
actually right now the favorite
but you but it's like Democrats are like
guys Trump might win and then you get
these never Charmers like nope nope he
won't win he can't well they have to
keep that narrative up to try and get
their Republicans to not vote for Trump
I mean yeah because they're trying to
get into santis because he's the best
they have yeah and it's just it's just
oh man you know what I love let's just
let's just let's just go there quickly
Laura Loomer does not work for Donald
Trump
right and so when she posts nonsense
you're like I don't know whatever but
the DeSantis crowd gets super offended
by it and then people who actually do
work for DeSantis react similarly right
and then when people are like hey the
official campaign you guys should not do
this they go but Laura Loomer did it and
it's like okay look I'll also add this
when the class clown is you know
throwing spitballs at the at the front
board while making jokes and everyone's
laughing
and you're enjoying the silliness and
then the nerdy kid stands up turns
around and starts yelling at the class
clown
you're you're not gonna be you're the
the nerdy kid's not getting popularity
like the preppy little teacher's pet and
the Loomer is the class clown in the
situation absolutely like the the the
the Trump
supporters online who do not work for
Trump are posting memes making jokes
when they said that bill Mitchell looked
like an aging lesbian everyone on the
answer the online starts laughing
hilariously it's a dig it's an attack
and then the response from the tennis
people is I am outraged how dare you
insult me I now have carte blanche to
insult everyone else and it's like
you're not being funny you're not being
funny right you're you are getting
played by these people and complaining
about them but you're making yourself
look worse I'm sorry man look I'm not
saying it's good I'm saying Trump
they've been doing this for eight years
the Trump support us for eight years
they have mastered the meme they hold
them into office exactly you're not
going to compete by by pouting and
stomping your feet and saying it's not
fair um with Bruce I think is that Alex
brucewood that did the Aging lesbian
joke
um is he working with Trump right now
because he was before he's part of X I
believe it's called X strategies I think
that's what it's called I'm not sure but
I I I don't think he's an official
member of the campaign but I'm not
entirely sure my campaign's playing The
Troll and meme game it's a very
important part of politics these days
there's no doubt about it you you can't
you can't claim the right for your
campaign's official staff to start
insulting everyone because a handful of
people have insulted you yeah that's how
you lose
and getting triggered is a loss at this
point I'm like DeSantis deserves to lose
because he won't fire these people and
they keep doing it what happened today
was this one guy posted an image where
they did a search of all these different
personalities me included about
hurricane Adalia and they were like
these people some of them living in
Florida won't even tweet about this for
political reasons get the hell out of
this state or whatever I don't even live
in Florida and I I had just recorded a
video where I was praising DeSantis
response in Florida and I'm like look
man I'm sorry the DeSantis surrogates
are trying to get him to lose right
that's the only explanation because it's
like why would you lie like they lied
about Matt Gates and they lied about a
lot about Vivek Matt Gates has been
posting Non-Stop about the hurricane and
and disaster preparedness even posting
uh statements from Rhonda santis and
then you've got Vivek who said you know
you know he gave uh credit to Santa
saying you're doing a good job keep it
up and then they put out these lies this
guy I don't know if he actually works
for the campaign but that's the
accusation because what they do is they
have these text groups where they send
supporters memes to to basically create
I'll put it this way the son and red
video remember that one when when
DeSantis appears with the black song the
black Sun bottom yes yeah can you
believe that that is called the son and
rat video now it is but it is obviously
apparently what happened was the
official campaign produced the video and
then gave it to a third party saying
post this and we'll retweet it
yeah of course anyway so dumb anyway we
have a nice little clip of that uh that
part of that video in my campaign video
but it's just from just a quick glance
oh we're talking about because we just
make fun of all politicians I am the Emu
says shout out to Josh and crew love
from Sean Burton in the Burton Family oh
that's uh yeah very long time family
friend awesome nice thank you neboop
says 50 round mags and full auto
handguns stop I can only get so hard
we coming baby we're coming no those
videos when they're running around them
are crazy but it's like it comes all the
way down like the truth is they're so
hard to control oh yeah
nuts for you whatever
train get out and train I train I do
trade but I trade I I'm uh first of all
I'm a Beretta guy I like my spaghetti
guys
I'm a spaghetti guy carry 92x all the
time audio I don't have a red dog though
all right acoustic Theory says we are
closer to Weimar than ever before they
will say Trump is our Hitler destined to
rise out of the political Strife because
of their arrogance the left can't see
themselves in the mirror or they don't
care to they know what they're doing
Communists and getting close to
something doesn't mean you're more
likely to arrive there because things
can swivel back and forth we are pretty
close to Weimar but we're on the edge of
an energy Revolution where we start
using hydrogen fuel and dipping the cost
of fuel by like you know one one
millionth of a set like we might be able
to drastically reduce the cost of fuel
and energy which could Elevate our
economy to a place that it has never
been before do you think they'll do that
though because we see with medicine we
know there's a lot of stuff that can be
cured and they're not in the business of
curing humans they want us to stay sick
why would they give us the benefit of a
major energy breakthrough why would they
just keep charging us and just give us a
little bit a little bit and they just
reap the rewards to prevent do you
really trust like Civil War energy
companies to have Humanity in their best
interest well I mean if you could leave
it to the corporations I don't think
they'll you know help us out but if the
people in the in the government take
control of our energy
uh it would be to prevent civil unrest
basically and and update our
Navy geez what update the Navy man we
need better fuel sources is it that uh
oil is so nasty and heavy Let's uh we're
talking about the FM what's that dfm
diesel
like diesel powered any of that any of
that petroleum-based stuff is just heavy
and I'm most caring I'm sure nukes at
this point I don't want to spend that
kind of money like oh it doesn't cost
money now they figured out with hydrogen
you take methane which is CH4 you break
rating upgrading the Navy will cost
money
well it will cost resources yeah and but
if we can acquire the resources it's
worth doing and then who does the labor
humans they will have to talk to you and
how do you and what do you do to
convince the human to do the job
Phil I would like you to carry a heavy
box down the stairs oh you pay them
money oh money I mean well I'm I'm you
say you want to update but I'm not I'm
like I don't I don't understand because
I feel like like we have like a
state-of-the-art Navy like wait it's not
like our Navy is like falling behind
anyone and and we spend a boatload of
money so I'm not sure what we should
like what you're looking to upgrade like
half of our the big ships are nuclear
powered like your submarines and your
aircraft carriers and I think some of
your destroyers but then like I'm not
sure what you're looking to upgrade to
there's going to be some fossil fuels
that they have there are you saying get
them all off no no getting off oil is
impossible because of lubricants well I
mean that's right
he's talking about when they talk about
wind turbines they don't realize you
need oil those ships have so much Lube
oil in them oh yeah I I fought a Lube
oil fire for two and a half days on a
carrier so it's like a it's a globe
everywhere that's a lot of lube it's a
risk to have all that oil what they say
about the Navy I mean hydrogen's
flammable too but it's also very
lightweight and could be discharged
pretty easy I want to read one more
Super Chat before we go and uh it's from
the bonus holes he says definitely don't
add our band on X at the bonus holes the
algorithm would not like it if you did
that's a cool name and uh just on that
note I just wanted to mention that video
that Phil put up of him performing in
front of this sold out massive stadium
was just absolutely epic it was awesome
and I was super super fortunate to be
able to do it so people should check
that out on uh what's your what's your
what's your X account I am uh Phil that
remains on X yeah go ahead that video is
just Bonkers to see that what a dream
man yeah drink I mean look Metallica is
the biggest band in the world yeah
they're the biggest metal band ever I've
been a Metalhead since I was a kid so
obviously it was a dream come true and
I'm just super happy that I could help
my friends out and you opened right
before Metallica Yeah so basically
everyone's piling in to watch your set
they weren't even actually watched
Metallica they weren't even hammered yet
did they call you on Wednesday and we're
like can you come do the show Zoltan
sent me a 10 when I was doing PCC on
Thursday and I was like hold on I gotta
finish I'm doing a podcast I talked to
him on Thursday night I had to come here
and do the podcast at night I talked to
him afterwards and he's like hey can you
get on a plane so I was like yeah so I
went and drove to my apartment grabbed
Django drove to New England to drop her
off so that my roommate up buying place
in New Hampshire can watch the dog
jumped on a flight flew to L.A got there
on Saturday played on Sunday got on a
plane on Monday flew back grabbed the
dog drove back down here yesterday and
I'm here now all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member by going to
timcast.com clicking join us and you can
also download the timcast app on the
Google Play Store Apple to come soon
that members only show will be starting
soon you can follow the show at timcast
IRL basically everywhere you can follow
me personally everywhere at timcast Josh
you want to shout anything out yeah sure
you guys follow me at Twitter it's at
Joshua at large all spelled out and then
of course the campaign website is Joshua
smith2024 dot com I saw a lot of people
asking about this hoodie it's a it says
a vote for vengeance and it is for sale
on our campaign website right on I am
filibonti I am Phil that remains on X I
am filler remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
check us out on Apple music Spotify
Amazon music Pandora YouTube you know
the internet man and I'm Ian Crossland
you guys check out the uh Tim cast IRL
live event in Miami coming up October
6th I believe it is October 6th we got
Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates Patrick Bet
David hosted by Tim Poole and Luke
gradkowski I'll be there more guests
more people to name uh and you can go to
the timcast.com hit the banner at the
top to go buy a ticket also I'm very
serious about retrofitting our economy
to start using hydrogen fuel they had a
huge breakthrough where they're able to
split methane and uh turn the carbon
aspect of it into graphene and the
hydrogen aspect into fuel so it's
actually makes money to make hydrogen
you come out with a product that you can
sell and uh we're just about raising
awareness it's my it's my PIN tweet on X
so check it out and follow me there at
Ian Crossland uh you guys can follow me
on X at Kellen PDL and last Friday with
fresh and fit and they said no one
watches women's sports well uh Nebraska
volleyball just set the world record for
most uh largest attendance at a women's
sporting event that was like 92 000.
whoa yeah lots of people like you know
women's volleyball so they're making you
look better that's crazy I Wonder Why
women's volleyball is awesome okay like
they're not in bad shape it is a fun
watch man but I've seen some really good
videos you see those crazy videos where
it's like they they the ball's in play
for like a minute they're all just
diving I'm like wow there's glasses yes
did you shut your yeah yeah I did of
Kellin PDL thanks all right everybody we
will see you all over at timcast.com in
about a minute thanks for hanging out